Hey guys, this is Joel and this is the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. The last episode that we did, this is a part two, The last one was about making meaning, um, and kind of a broken world and how psychology has to change in response to some paradoxes that are happening. You know, the world changes. Psychology is teaching you, or, you know, clinical psychology therapy is teaching you how to, um, respond to being an individual in a world. That world changes the way that you are an individual has to change. And then therefore, um, the way that therapy is helping you, um, bounce those two balls back and forth of sort of self and world have to change. And so that first episode, um, and that, that making meaning series about what needs to change in psychology or things that psychology has to
大家好，我是乔尔，这是“主根疗法集体”（Taproot Therapy Collective）播客。我们上一期节目是关于“创造意义”的，这是第二部分。上一期讨论的是在一个破碎的世界中如何创造意义，以及心理学如何应对当前出现的一些悖论。你知道，世界在变。心理学在教你，或者说临床心理治疗在教你，如何作为一个个体去应对这个世界。世界变了，你作为个体的方式也必须随之改变。因此，治疗帮助你平衡“自我”与“世界”这两者的方式也必须改变。所以，第一期节目以及关于心理学需要做出哪些改变、心理学必须适应什么或考虑什么新事物的系列讨论，其实只是在提出问题。
adapt or new things that it has to consider was just sort of asking questions. Um, and the point was not to be a new model of therapy or to create like a new technique. Um, it was just to sit with things that I was seeing, um, patients bring in that I didn't feel like traditional therapy was maybe ready to deal with. And so this is, um, more speculative cause I, I got a couple, uh, you know, emails already of people being like, you say this, but then what are we supposed to do? And I'm trying to tell you that there is something that we all need to do, but it is a personal thing, um, that about learning to do a process to articulate our own voice, a lot like therapy. And that means that I can't tell you how to do it, right? And then I'll proceed to talk for an hour about how
重点并不是要建立一种新的治疗模式或创造一种新技术。我只是想坐下来，审视一下我所看到的患者带来的问题，我觉得传统疗法可能还没准备好处理这些问题。所以，这一期更具推测性，因为我已经收到几封邮件，人们说：“你说了这些，那我们到底该怎么办？”我想告诉你们，我们确实都需要做些什么，但这是一种个人的事情，关于学习如何通过一个过程来表达我们自己的声音，这很像治疗。这意味着我无法告诉你具体该怎么做，对吧？然后我还会继续讲一个小时关于
there are still things that you can consider that can get you there. And so another way of looking at the points that I brought up in that first one, um, are that I think there's like three things that we have to change how we conceptualize in therapy. And one is like coming up with a coherent, um, definition of self. And the next one is dealing with implicit memory, which is a big question, which comes up in almost every model of therapy. Um, but there's confusion about what it is. You'll
你仍然可以考虑哪些事情能带你达到那个目标。所以，看待我在第一期中提出的观点的另一种方式是，我认为我们在治疗中必须改变对三件事的构思。第一是提出一个连贯的“自我”定义；第二是处理内隐记忆，这是一个大问题，几乎出现在每一种治疗模式中，但人们对它是什么存在困惑。你会
see two people talking about implicit memory, but they're disagreeing. One person's being like, well, there isn't an unconscious, but we just have somatic protective reactions. And it's like, I don't know, man, the things that I see on LinkedIn, not targeted at me and sometimes sent to me, you know, in a targeted way privately, I just don't even know what is happening in this field because people are getting degrees with no education. I mean, like the, the ability of somebody to say, well, Carl Jung is completely pseudoscientific and then post how they're embodying the archetype of like Mars and retrograde or or just the the therapist that looks the post looks more normal about um you know Jung and Freud are old and you know Freud
看到两个人都在谈论内隐记忆，但他们的观点却不一致。一个人会说：“嗯，根本没有潜意识，我们只有躯体保护性反应。”我不知道，伙计，我在领英（LinkedIn）上看到的东西，不是针对我的，有时是私下发给我的，我甚至不知道这个领域到底发生了什么，因为人们在没有受过教育的情况下就拿到了学位。我的意思是，有人能说“卡尔·荣格完全是伪科学”，然后又发帖说他们正在体现“火星逆行”的原型，或者有些治疗师发的帖子看起来更正常，谈论荣格和弗洛伊德太老了，弗洛伊德
is more evidence-based than Jung but uh you know neither is evidence-based at all or you know something like that and then you look on their wall and they're like an IFS therapist, which it's like IFS is what happens when you put gestalt therapy together with Carl Jung. And you can ask Richard Schwartz, like he'll tell you in the intro of his book. I mean, you can read that model and not see how these things work. I mean, it's like indicative of this bigger problem, which is like people act like these things, these models of therapy like fell from heaven.
比荣格更有循证依据，但你知道，两者其实都没有循证依据，或者类似的话，然后你去看他们的主页，发现他们是IFS（内在家庭系统）治疗师，而IFS其实就是把格式塔疗法和卡尔·荣格结合在一起的产物。你可以去问理查德·施瓦茨（Richard Schwartz），他在书的序言里会告诉你。我的意思是，你可以读读那个模型，看看这些东西是如何运作的。这说明了一个更大的问题，就是人们表现得好像这些治疗模型是从天上掉下来的一样。
They're not part of a timeline that is, you know, certain men, certain women, certain groups of people trying to solve like larger cultural problems or solving the larger cultural trends. I mean, everyone acting like this thing is in a vacuum i think is this result of the way not just that we do i mean really the way that we do modern academia around psychology is everybody is so specialized that it's like they don't know anything i'm sorry like i know i'm a liberal arts you know humanities kid or whatever but like you have to back up and know the history of how you got here to know what you know. And if you don't know that, you don't know very much.
它们不是一个时间线的一部分，不是某些男人、某些女人、某些群体试图解决更大的文化问题或解决更大的文化趋势的结果。我的意思是，每个人都表现得好像这东西是在真空中存在一样，我认为这是现代心理学学术界运作方式的结果。每个人都太专业化了，以至于他们什么都不知道。抱歉，我知道我是个文科生，或者别的什么，但你必须退后一步，了解你是如何走到这一步的历史，才能知道你所知道的东西。如果你不知道这些，你就所知甚少。
Here's a cost proposition for you. See if you want to buy this oceanfront property. Ready? Okay, so there's this cool thing that you can do. You can write a paper, and it'll be really hard, and you have to have an original idea, and you have to do it in a certain language, which is pretty counterintuitive, but it's its own language.
给你出一个成本命题。看看你想不想买这块海滨房产。准备好了吗？好的，有一件很酷的事情你可以做。你可以写一篇论文，这会非常困难，你必须有一个原创的想法，而且你必须用某种特定的语言来写，这相当反直觉，但它有自己的一套语言。
It doesn't really help your point shine or anything, but there's a certain way that we have to do it to make sure that the people who are talking are serious people who know what they're talking about. Without the system, we can't have that. Oh, that's cool. So do I get a lot of money if I publish an academic paper? Oh, no, actually, you don't get any money from it. Oh, that's neat because I'm getting my idea out there and I would
它并不能真正让你的观点脱颖而出，但我们必须以某种特定的方式来做，以确保那些正在交流的人是严肃的、知道自己在谈论什么的人。没有这个系统，我们就无法做到这一点。哦，那很酷。那么如果我发表一篇学术论文，我能得到很多钱吗？哦，不，实际上你从中学不到任何钱。哦，那太好了，因为我把我的想法传达出去了，我
get to be able to maybe publish that later in a way that I would make money or if there's an idea in there that's good, I could get the copyright. Oh, no, no. Actually, you give your copyright away. You work really hard and you come up with all of these new ideas. And then you just give that away to a company that publishes your work. Oh, that's cool. Because they're probably like a nonprofit that's helping academia, you know, accomplish its ends. And we're all in this together. No, no, actually, they make more money than Google. One of the biggest profit makers, like in the world of corporate, the corporate world that we don't talk about are academic libraries. Like they just take, uh, the stuff that you make for free, um, and the right to republish it indefinitely forever and to charge for it. And if there's any monetizable
以后也许能以某种方式发表它来赚钱，或者如果里面有一个好的想法，我可以获得版权。哦，不，不。实际上，你把版权交出去了。你非常努力地工作，想出了所有这些新想法。然后你只是把它们送给了一家出版你作品的公司。哦，那很酷。因为他们可能是一个非营利组织，正在帮助学术界实现其目标。我们都在一起努力。不，不，实际上，他们赚的钱比谷歌还多。在企业界，我们不谈论的最大利润制造者之一就是学术图书馆。他们只是拿走你免费制作的东西，以及无限期重新出版它的权利，并为此收费。如果里面有任何可货币化的
ideas in there, they get those two. Um, and they, they make, you know, uh, the biggest one made about a trillion dollars last year, you know, globally. Oh, okay, well, but, you know, a lot of people will read my stuff, right? You know, because it's a publisher, so they're getting it in front of. No, actually, people have to pay $400 a month to have access to any of that. So it's really just going to be kind of academics and colleges where their institution has, you know, some sort of bulk purchasing deal and they pay for it. Um, but yeah, you know, if you put it on a blog or a podcast, like if you're a social worker in Alabama and you did that and you had, you know, about, I don't know, 500 views on your blog articles, anywhere from, you know, 80 to 200 views on most of your podcasts, you would probably be seen by
想法，他们也一并拿走。他们去年在全球赚了大约一万亿美元。哦，好吧，但是，你知道，很多人会读我的东西，对吧？因为它是出版商，所以他们会把它展示给别人看。不，实际上，人们必须每月支付400美元才能获得任何这些内容的访问权限。所以它真的只是给那些机构有某种批量购买协议的学者和大学看的。但是，是的，如果你把它放在博客或播客上，比如如果你是阿拉巴马州的一名社会工作者，你做了这件事，并且你的博客文章有大约500次浏览，大多数播客有80到200次浏览，你可能会被
more people, but your impact factor would go up because all these people are citing your paper right so that's that's that's cool like uh like a lot of other academics cite the paper and then that helps my impact factor so that gets me a job in a college um the academics they're not probably reading the paper. They just need something to support their point. So they, they find, you know, if you write a real broad paper that, you know, grabs a lot of other things and cites them, it's, it's pretty likely to get cited, you know? So you, then you use that to get like a really good job, right? And then you make a ton of money. And actually as a, as a professor, you don't, you know, a lot of the people that I correspond
更多人看到，但你的影响因子会上升，因为所有这些人都在引用你的论文，所以这很酷。就像很多其他学者引用这篇论文，然后这有助于我的影响因子，所以这能让我在大学里找到一份工作。那些学者可能并没有在读这篇论文。他们只是需要一些东西来支持他们的观点。所以他们发现，如果你写了一篇非常广泛的论文，涵盖了很多其他东西并引用了它们，它很有可能被引用，你知道吗？所以你利用这一点来获得一份非常好的工作，对吧？然后你赚一大笔钱。实际上，作为一名教授，你并不会，你知道，我与之通信的很多人
with about the academic stuff that I'm interested in are these kind of older professors. If they're not a guest on the podcast, I don't want to say who they are. And they're pretty... A lot of them are not doing well. Big names, big successful people that were in academia their entire life. And they didn't really make any money. And they published a lot.
关于我感兴趣的学术问题的人都是这些老教授。如果他们不是播客的嘉宾，我不想说他们是谁。他们相当……他们中很多人过得并不好。大人物，在学术界工作了一辈子的成功人士。他们并没有真正赚到什么钱。而且他们发表了很多文章。
You wouldn't know who most of them are, I would think. And, oh, you know what, though? I think that you're forgetting peer review. I mean, the point of these things, the reason why, you know, these academic libraries have to suck up all this money for not really doing anything beyond Google Drive, right? Google Drive to just host a bunch of text documents without videos and images is like $20 a month, but they cost $400.
我想你可能不知道他们大多数人是谁。而且，你知道吗？我觉得你忘了同行评审了。我的意思是，这些事情的意义，为什么这些学术图书馆必须吸走这么多钱，却除了谷歌云端硬盘（Google Drive）之外什么都没做，对吧？谷歌云端硬盘托管一堆没有视频和图像的文本文档每月只需20美元，但他们却要收400美元。
But that $400 just puts really good use because there's this, you know, yeah, the academic libraries, they don't have to pay for it, but the journals themselves, which a lot of times, you know, operate at break-even or a loss or, you know, donations, you know, they peer review the things.
但这400美元只是用在了真正好的地方，因为有这个，你知道，是的，学术图书馆不需要为此付费，但期刊本身，很多时候，你知道，是在盈亏平衡或亏损或靠捐款运营，他们会对这些东西进行同行评审。
So a group of peers make sure that the paper is like serious and important and good and top and oh wait yeah no actually some of the biggest journals in the world have these stupidest articles on psychology that I have ever read I mean if you say the point of it out loud you would laugh But when you hide it in academic language, it's like when you were a kid and you got Microsoft PowerPoint and you didn't have any idea what to say about Bolivia, but you put a picture of a tennis ball and a fire truck and a, you know, a fighter jet and then whoosh, bing, cling, it's all coming in. You just disguise that
所以一群同行确保论文是严肃的、重要的、好的、顶尖的，等等，等等。哦，等等，不，实际上世界上一些最大的期刊上刊登着我读过的关于心理学最愚蠢的文章。我的意思是，如果你大声说出它的重点，你会笑出来的。但当你把它隐藏在学术语言中时，就像你小时候拿到微软PowerPoint，你根本不知道关于玻利维亚该说什么，但你放了一张网球、一辆消防车和一架战斗机的图片，然后“嗖”、“叮”、“哐”，全都出来了。你只是掩盖了
you really didn't know anything about Bolivia by making a PowerPoint presentation. There's great academic papers out there, but I don't know, man, that peer review thing, it doesn't really keep them out because every time a rich guy wants to write an op-ed, they can just continue to resubmit and pay money until the Lancet will just go ahead and put it out there. So that doesn't really hold up't really hold up either. Um, you know, but it's for this greater good, right? Because it gives you the ability. Yeah. You don't get any money and then everyone else makes the money and then they make trillions of dollars off of your labor that you give away for free. And then you use it to get a job that also doesn't pay you any money. But, um, there's a, you know, a cool thing that happens where I get to go out and discover like a new idea and just do something really cool. That's uniquely me and get it in front of some of
你通过制作PowerPoint演示文稿，实际上对玻利维亚一无所知。外面有很棒的学术论文，但我不知道，伙计，那个同行评审的事情，它并没有真正把它们挡在外面，因为每次一个有钱人想写一篇评论文章，他们都可以不断重新提交并付钱，直到《柳叶刀》直接把它发出来。所以这在逻辑上也站不住脚。嗯，但这都是为了更大的利益，对吧？因为它给了你能力。是的。你得不到任何钱，然后其他人赚了钱，然后他们用你免费贡献的劳动赚了数万亿美元。然后你用它来找一份也不给你钱的工作。但是，嗯，有一件很酷的事情发生了，我可以出去发现一个新想法，做一些真正酷的事情。那是独属于我的，并把它展示给一些
the smartest people in the world that have access to academic libraries and they read it, right? Oh no, actually you don't because you have to find a person who is doing this, um, who needs help publishing their papers to get their impact factor out there and when you're in school for ten years doing psych I have a lot of friends in stem this is not necessarily applicable to stem this is talking about academic psychology um you have to find like an old guy who's like 30 years out of touch and do what he wants you to research and if they don't really want it doesn't line up or help theirs then then you can't do it. So usually it's something really great that we really need, you know, it's reinventing
世界上最聪明的人，他们有权访问学术图书馆，他们读了它，对吧？哦，不，实际上你没有，因为你必须找到一个正在做这件事的人，他需要帮助发表论文以提高他们的影响因子。当你读了十年心理学时，我有很多STEM领域的朋友，这不一定适用于STEM，这是在谈论学术心理学。你必须找到一个与世隔绝30年的老家伙，做他想让你研究的东西，如果他们真的不想要，或者不符合他们的研究，那么你就不能做。所以通常是一些我们真正需要的非常伟大的东西，你知道，它正在重塑
the field because after 10 years of studying, you can come up with something like a new 30 question screener for anxiety. You know, when you've got that PhD and you've made all of these compromises and sacrifices, you can come up with 30 questions that we can give to someone to ask another person to know if that patient has anxiety. I mean, doesn't that just titillate you, you know? But, I mean, what if we just made people go into maybe therapy who don't need 30 questions to tell if the person across from them is anxious and where that comes from and what kind of anxiety it is maybe we could just get kind of you know remember we started this conversation
这个领域，因为学习了10年之后，你可以想出一些东西，比如一个新的30题焦虑筛查表。你知道，当你拿到那个博士学位，做出了所有这些妥协和牺牲后，你可以想出30个问题，我们可以给某人，去问另一个人，以了解该患者是否有焦虑症。我的意思是，这难道不让你感到兴奋吗？但是，我的意思是，如果我们只是让那些不需要30个问题就能判断对面的人是否焦虑、焦虑从何而来以及是什么类型的焦虑的人去接受治疗，那会怎样？也许我们可以只是，你知道，记得我们开始这段对话时
saying like how can we make sure that the smart, discerning, intuitive people are in charge? You know, the direction of where it goes. Oh, well, because we don't want to pay anyone who does therapy and we don't want to vet them to make sure that they are smart or intuitive. So they're going to need those 30 questions because we don't trust them to come up with three of their own. So they're really going to need your screener. Okay, like that is our system. And I'm a social worker. I'm a therapist. A lot of people critique me for, you know, being a social worker because it's racist or whatever. I get, you know, ableist that I don't know, I get email emails from people all over the place, left and right. And then a lot of people get angry that like I take insurance, which I'll take it as long as it helps more people than it hurts. Not a huge fan of our
说的是，我们如何确保聪明、有洞察力、直觉敏锐的人负责？你知道，它发展的方向。哦，好吧，因为我们不想付钱给任何做治疗的人，我们也不想审查他们以确保他们聪明或直觉敏锐。所以他们会需要那30个问题，因为我们不相信他们能自己想出三个问题。所以他们真的会需要你的筛查表。好吧，这就是我们的系统。我是一名社会工作者。我是一名治疗师。很多人批评我，因为我是社会工作者，因为这很种族主义或者别的什么。我收到来自各地的邮件，左左右右。然后很多人很生气，因为我接受保险，只要它帮助的人多于伤害的人，我就会接受。我不太喜欢我们
current system. So I mean, I've made sacrifices. Like I do things where I can critique the system. You can say, hey, this is bad about that. We shouldn't distribute resources and power this way. And I'll be like, yeah, that's right. Okay. So if you're an academic who is enjoying what you do and you love what you do and you made these sacrifices to do something you love great i'm not talking about you who i'm talking about is the person who goes well actually we need these things because they've always been there or how else would you want to do it you know we'll get to that in the in the third section and the third thing that psychiatry has you know psychology like academic psychology is going to have to address if it's going to continue to stay in the business of
目前的系统。所以，我的意思是，我做出了牺牲。我做了一些事情，我可以批评这个系统。你可以说，嘿，这方面很糟糕。我们不应该这样分配资源和权力。我会说，是的，那是对的。好吧。所以，如果你是一位享受你所做的事情、热爱你所做的事情并且为了做你热爱的事情而做出这些牺牲的学者，很好，我不是在说你。我所说的是那些说“好吧，实际上我们需要这些东西，因为它们一直都在那里”或者“你还能怎么做呢”的人。你知道，我们会在第三部分讨论这个问题，这是精神病学，你知道，心理学，学术心理学如果想继续从事
therapy um and it is people who are just carrying water for bad ideas because it threatens them that you point these things out they just don't want to think about it okay like i you know hell i may go back to school and get a phd or something one day the point of this isn't The PhDs are stupid. It's not the PhDs are bad It's that this system is bad right and if you can't point at that and you can't say that Then that's your shadow. There's something wrong with you that is saying no no no no no no don't look at objective reality You have to defend the current system because it's there for a reason okay? I can't tell you what the reason is I just know that there is a reason because you know the other people that
治疗业务，就必须解决的第三件事。而且有些人只是在为坏主意背书，因为你指出这些事情威胁到了他们，他们只是不想去想它。好吧，就像我，你知道，见鬼，我有一天可能会回到学校去拿个博士学位什么的。这并不是说博士们很蠢。并不是说博士们很糟糕。而是这个系统很糟糕，对吧？如果你不能指出这一点，你不能说出来，那么这就是你的阴影。你身上有什么东西在说“不，不，不，不，不，不，不要看客观现实，你必须捍卫当前的系统，因为它存在是有原因的”。好吧，我不能告诉你原因是什么，我只知道有一个原因，因为你知道，其他那些
are smart probably did it okay this is the system that is making the smart people and vetting them and making sure like that so you know this to segue in from last time we talked about the hyper rationality of our current world. And I think to try and live within these objective systems to try and turn everything into a number to try and vet everything to try and turn, you know, you can do this with science, you know, until you get to quantum physics, and you have to start using metaphors, again, science can be pretty objective and empirical. Psychology is a soft science., and to try and pretend that it isn't to try and pretend that it is this hard science where we can empirically look at everything
聪明的人可能做到了。好吧，这是正在培养聪明人并审查他们，确保他们……所以，你知道，为了从上次我们谈论的我们当前世界的过度理性化过渡过来。我认为，试图生活在这些客观系统中，试图把一切都变成数字，试图审查一切，试图把……你知道，你可以用科学做到这一点，直到你接触到量子物理学，你必须再次开始使用隐喻。科学可以是相当客观和经验性的。心理学是一门软科学，试图假装它不是，试图假装它是一门我们可以凭经验观察一切的硬科学
and we don't ever have to have any intuition or just like sense of self or sense of awareness, um, or that our subjective reactions aren't important is insane. Okay. Like the, the hyper-rationality that I talked about in that the first one it's this madness that arises like not from no logic but from too much of it from thinking that all we are are logic and trying to build a world out of it and this kind of academic system which is very useful to um you know a lot of very moneyed forces like the way that the dod does research the way that we want to like fund things like it's those, like the way that the DOD does research, the way that we want to like fund things. Like it's those, that's the reason that it exists in its current iteration,
而且我们永远不需要任何直觉或自我意识或觉知感，或者我们的主观反应不重要，这是疯狂的。好吧。就像我在第一期中谈到的过度理性化，这是一种疯狂，不是源于没有逻辑，而是源于逻辑太多，源于认为我们所拥有的只是逻辑，并试图用它建立一个世界。这种学术系统，对很多非常有钱的势力非常有用，比如国防部（DOD）做研究的方式，我们想要资助事物的方式，就像那些，国防部做研究的方式，我们想要资助事物的方式。就像那些，这就是它以当前形式存在的原因，
you know, academia and these systems, like, and I'm not saying it's all bad. I'm saying that's the reason that they exist. And, you know, these people now are talking about large language models and like all this stuff. And those people who want to say that you can turn, um, you know, basically robots into people by, you know, a large language model is a search engine, a large language model. It's just a predictive algorithm. It's a spreadsheet that is going through thousands of little bits of data and saying, every time this word was used in proximity with these other words, it and saying every time this word was used in proximity with these other words it was very likely that this word would be used or the context would be
你知道，学术界和这些系统，而且我不是说这全是坏事。我是说这就是它们存在的原因。而且，你知道，这些人现在在谈论大型语言模型和所有这些东西。那些想要说你可以通过大型语言模型把机器人变成人的人，大型语言模型是一个搜索引擎，大型语言模型。它只是一个预测算法。它是一个电子表格，正在浏览成千上万的小数据位，并说，每次这个词与这些其他词一起使用时，它……并说每次这个词与这些其他词一起使用时，它很有可能使用这个词，或者上下文会是
this word which shares the same contextual you know uh placement 86.9 percent of the time so it's a good bet but it's it's probability it's not thinking you know i use them i use them to collate data because that's what they're for but the people talking about this going to be sentient like this thing going to be alive like the people who are saying that you can turn robots into people are saying that because they are so cut off from the thing that i'm talking about next self that they believe that you can turn people into robots. And, and not only that, like their attempt to turn themselves into robots is what is good about them.
这个词，它在86.9%的时间里共享相同的上下文位置，所以这是一个很好的赌注，但这是概率，不是思考。你知道，我使用它们，我使用它们来整理数据，因为这就是它们的用途。但那些谈论这个东西会产生感知、这个东西会活过来的人，就像那些说你可以把机器人变成人的人，他们之所以这么说，是因为他们与我接下来要谈的“自我”完全隔绝了，以至于他们相信你可以把人变成机器人。而且，不仅如此，他们试图把自己变成机器人，这正是他们身上好的地方。
And the system rewards people who think that like that. All right. Now back off and go back to what I said, I was going to talk about, which are some ways that are, you know, sort of practical. I'll call them pseudo practical ways to make the changes that I was talking about in the first one to help people make sense of this world that is new with a psychology that has to be new which has to evolve I mean so much of my anger and what I'm talking about is people that think that
而且这个系统奖励那些那样想的人。好了。现在退后一步，回到我刚才说的，我打算谈论的内容，也就是一些实用的，我会称之为伪实用的方法，来做出我在第一期中谈到的改变，以帮助人们理解这个新的世界，用一个必须是新的、必须进化的心理学。我的意思是，我愤怒的很大一部分，以及我所谈论的，是那些认为
these things don't need to change and you're not talking about algebra right like you're talking about psychology of course it has to change like clinical psychology look at the difference in the world look at the difference in the culture look at the speed of culture and and I'm I'm trying to bring up things that I feel you know intuitively that I see with patients that I think that as a field we have to sit with to change. And so, you know, the first one is going to be this idea of self. And, you know, self is a big word, right? Like it's a little word, but it means who the person is, which is saying what the point of therapy is.
这些东西不需要改变的人。你谈论的不是代数，对吧？你谈论的是心理学，当然它必须改变。看看临床心理学，看看世界的差异，看看文化的差异，看看文化的速度。我试图提出一些我直觉上感受到的、我在患者身上看到的、我认为作为一个领域我们必须坐下来去改变的事情。所以，你知道，第一个就是这个“自我”的概念。而且，你知道，“自我”是一个大词，对吧？它是一个小词，但它意味着一个人是谁，这也就是在说治疗的意义是什么。
And what I mean by that is like, if I say somebody comes in and they're like, you know, my, my husband, you know, hits me and I need to figure out ways to be a better wife and better Christian and let him do that, you know, cause I'm sometimes fight back. I think most therapists, most people who are armchair, you know, therapists or whatever would say, oh, that's not her real self, right? It's the job of the therapist to help her get in touch with her real self so that she knows that that's unhealthy and that she can leave. Okay. But that's a pretty extreme example. I mean, how far do you take that?
我的意思是，如果我说有人进来，他们说：“你知道，我丈夫打我，我需要找出方法做一个更好的妻子和更好的基督徒，让他那样做，因为我有时会反抗。”我想大多数治疗师，大多数业余治疗师或别的什么人会说：“哦，那不是她真正的自我，对吧？”治疗师的工作是帮助她与她真正的自我取得联系，这样她就知道那是不健康的，她可以离开。好吧。但这是一个相当极端的例子。我的意思是，你把它带到什么程度？
There's a lot of people who, when I say, you know, I can tell that this person is like brilliant, that they're funny, that like they really want to create something, but they just don't have a language for it yet. They don't know if it's going to be through business. They don't know if it's going to be for this. Yeah, you know, I need to make sure that I'm being patient-centered and not projecting my own ambition. To say projecting my own ambition is really funny because I'm not a terribly ambitious guy. Things kind of keep happening to me, which is funny, but not. Anyway, like, yeah, I need to make sure that I don't muddy the waters and decide the goals for the patient.
有很多人，当我说：“你知道，我能看出这个人很聪明，他们很有趣，他们真的很想创造一些东西，但他们还没有语言来表达它。”他们不知道这是否会通过商业实现。他们不知道这是否会为了这个。是的，你知道，我需要确保我是以患者为中心的，而不是投射我自己的野心。说“投射我自己的野心”真的很有趣，因为我不是一个非常有野心的人。事情总是发生在我身上，这很有趣，但也不是。总之，是的，我需要确保我不会把水搅浑，并为患者决定目标。
But most of these models of therapy that are cognitive and especially the ones that are just behavioral, you know, like they're saying that if it's not on the treatment plan, it's not real. And it can't put it on the treatment plan unless the patient asks for it. Oh, but the patient can't ask for it until they know who they are. Catch-22, I guess we've made therapy real simple. It's 1980. I mean, that's kind of what they did, like, with the cognitive revolution. When we came in, we got rid of this idea of, of like that you went into therapy to find out who you were and there is something to that like i think i'm not going to defend 20 years of psychoanalysis when no one can afford it to the people who do
但大多数这些认知治疗模型，尤其是那些纯行为主义的模型，你知道，他们说如果它不在治疗计划上，它就不是真实的。而且除非患者要求，否则不能把它放在治疗计划上。哦，但患者在知道自己是谁之前无法要求它。第22条军规，我想我们已经把治疗变得很简单了。那是1980年。我的意思是，这正是他们所做的，就像认知革命一样。当我们进来时，我们摆脱了这种想法，即你进行治疗是为了找出你是谁，而且这其中有一些道理。我想我不会为20年的精神分析辩护，当没有人能负担得起它时，对那些做
that i wouldn't see as therapists and then like three i just don't think that most of the things that they were digging up actually were making anyone change. I think they were just changing around the therapy. You know, when Freud is telling, like, little Hans that he's afraid of horses because he saw one fall over in the street and it wasn't just, like, a giant horse scared a kid. It actually was secretly about castration or whatever. And I know everyone was, like, makes fun of the Freudians for being too sexual but psychoanalysis I mean the the sexualism of the absurdity is not the problem the absurdity is the problem like if you're doing Lacanian psychoanalysis I don't know there was
这件事的人，我不会把他们视为治疗师。然后像第三点，我只是不认为他们挖掘出的大多数东西真的让任何人改变了。我认为他们只是在改变治疗本身。你知道，当弗洛伊德告诉小汉斯他害怕马是因为他看到一匹马在街上摔倒了，而不仅仅是一匹巨大的马吓到了孩子。实际上这秘密地是关于阉割或别的什么。我知道每个人都在嘲笑弗洛伊德派太色情了，但精神分析，我的意思是，荒谬的性欲并不是问题，荒谬本身才是问题。如果你在做拉康派精神分析，我不知道，有
like there's a joke that like if you ask a a classical psychoanalyst or like a a lacanian psychoanalyst like what what the point of therapy is they'll go out and they'll like write a book and still not tell you um and yeah like i that that's too much but how do we have this notion of self and like one of the reasons why I'm frustrated that we don't you know Teach and expect therapists to know more of the history is that they don't understand the assumptions of these models and these models are assuming Things you know therapists. It's like when you pick a religion and people are like well. You can't judge that person That's just their religion well I mean I kind of can because they picked that you know they're saying the thing so they're either not in touch with a part of themselves that doesn't believe these things or they actually believe them either one is bad so like yes i can have
一个笑话，如果你问一个古典精神分析师或拉康派精神分析师治疗的意义是什么，他们会出去写一本书，但仍然不告诉你。嗯，是的，那太过分了。但我们如何拥有这种“自我”的概念？我感到沮丧的原因之一是我们不教导并期望治疗师了解更多的历史，因为他们不理解这些模型的假设，而这些模型假设了一些东西。你知道，治疗师，这就像当你选择一种宗教时，人们会说：“好吧，你不能评判那个人，那是他们的宗教。”好吧，我的意思是，我确实可以，因为他们选择了那个，你知道，他们在说那件事。所以他们要么没有与自己不相信这些东西的部分取得联系，要么他们实际上相信它们，无论哪种都很糟糕。所以，是的，我可以有
an opinion about them therapy models are the same like you can look at me and you can judge me based on the amount of integration that i do that probably says something about me that i'm trying to find you know 800 different through lines through history and then figure out where it's going and like see through. Yeah, that probably says something about my ability to feel trapped. And then I feel trapped within the time that I'm in or I feel trapped within, you know, one human life, whatever. Yeah. I mean, of course, like the way that you practice therapy is going to be related to your own, you know, BS. Like, of course it is, which is why we have to be careful and be in touch with that.
关于他们的观点。治疗模型也是一样的。你可以看着我，你可以根据我所做的整合程度来评判我，这可能说明了一些关于我的事情，即我试图找到800条不同的历史脉络，然后弄清楚它要去向哪里，并看穿它。是的，这可能说明了我感到被困的能力。然后我感到被困在我所处的时代，或者我感到被困在一个人的一生中，无论什么。是的，我的意思是，当然，你进行治疗的方式将与你自己的胡说八道有关。当然是这样，这就是为什么我们必须小心并与它保持联系。
There's no getting rid of it. There's only being in touch with it. And so, you know, in that first section, I was talking about how, like, we need to see therapy as a more dynamic process. And I think a lot of times we view it as like a hierarchical thing. It's like, I'm going to go in at level one. I'm going to level up. I'm going to learn these mental health tips. I'm going to leave at level 28. Oops, I've had to set back on my
没有办法摆脱它。只有与它保持联系。所以，你知道，在第一部分中，我谈到了我们需要如何将治疗视为一个更动态的过程。我认为很多时候我们把它视为一种等级制度的东西。就像，我要在第一级进入。我要升级。我要学习这些心理健康技巧。我要在第28级离开。哎呀，我在第14级又遇到了挫折。我失去了我的装备。我要回去。它不是那样的，你知道，它不应该是那样的。治疗就像注意到某件事。而且它是注意到某件事，那就是你。对我来说，把“自我”拿出来说“患者在进入治疗之前必须确切地知道他们的目标是什么”是有点疯狂的，你知道吗？是的，目标可以改变。你可以改变你的治疗计划，无论什么。你需要有一些人们想要从中得到的东西。我的意思是，它必须与实际的事情有关。这不是，你知道，只是一个嬉皮士夏令营。我不是在为那个辩护。嗯，但是你可以进去说“我想要所有这些东西”的想法意味着你进入治疗时与某样东西取得了联系。而且，我们必须小心我们走多远。因为如果我们假设这个人进来只是因为他们有一个症状，而那个症状是治疗只是
level 14 again. I lost my gear. I'm going to go back. And it isn't that, you know, it shouldn't be. Therapy is like noticing something. And it's noticing something that is you. And to me, to take self and say, well, the patient has to know exactly what their goals are before they go into therapy is kind of wild, you know? And yeah, goals can change. You can change your treatment plan, whatever. And you need to have something that people want out of it. I mean, it has to be related to a practical thing. This isn't, you know, just a hippie summer camp. I'm not arguing for, for that. Um, but the idea that you could go in and say, I want all of these things means that you're coming into therapy in touch with something. And it's, we have to be careful how far we go with that. Because if we assume that the person is just coming in because they have a symptom and that symptom is something that therapy just
拿走的东西，而那并没有改变心理和人这个更大等式上的任何东西，那对我来说没有意义。为什么？我不相信大脑只是做一些不理性的事情。我不认为症状只是突然出现，然后我们可以进去摆脱它们，像肿瘤一样切除它们，或者像癌症一样用药治疗。我认为症状是不平衡的表现。除非你使用的模型让你能够坐下来玩弄平衡、投射等事情，否则你就不会明白外面的那个症状与里面的某种不理性的东西有关，对吧？就像，这种过度理性化已经做了那种事。而学术心理学已经随之而去了。这就是为什么
takes away and that that doesn't change anything on the larger equation of psyche in person, that doesn't make sense to me. Why? I don't believe that the brain just does things that are irrational. Like, I don't think that symptoms just pop up and then we can go in and get rid of them and have them cut off like tumors or medicated like cancer. I think that symptoms are an expression of an imbalance. And unless you're working with a model that lets you sit with playing with things like balance, things like projection, you know, then you don't understand that that symptom on the outside is related to something on the inside that isn't rational, right? Like, this hyper rationality has kind of done that. And academic psychology is run with it. And it's one of the reasons why
学术心理学正朝着与临床心理学完全不同的方向发展，这让我感到害怕。我并不真的想成为一名学术心理学家，但我意识到那是一件不健康的事情，对吧？如果他们在医院里告诉你，所有名字后面有头衔的人都在说“不，不，不，CBT（认知行为疗法）是黄金标准”。是的，我们在做研究时从来没能重现它。我们有重现性危机，我们似乎永远无法让它奏效，但我们仍然知道它是黄金标准，因为它是最可研究的，因此我们研究得最多，因此我们发现它最有效。而且我们必须把所有在计划完成之前就走掉的人从研究中剔除
academic psychology is going a completely different direction from clinical psychology, which is scary to me. I don't really want to be an academic psychologist, but I realized that that is an unhealthy thing, right? If the thing that they're telling you in the hospital, everybody who has all the letters behind their name is saying like, no, no, no, CBT is the gold standard. Yeah, we've never been able to reproduce it when we do the studies. We have a reproducibility crisis, and we can't seem to ever make it work, but we still know that it's the gold standard because it's the most researchable, and therefore we research it the most, and therefore that we find it's valid the most. And we have to remove everyone from the study who just walks off before their plan is completed
在CBT的第8到15次会话期间。他们不算数，因为他们没有完成治疗。好吧，他们走开是因为它太烂了。你为什么要从论文中把他们剔除？你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，心理学的重点，再次，你知道，第二部分是让人们有效地做某事，对吧？所以如果你必须扔掉所有走开的人
during session, you know, 8 through 15 of CBT. They don't count because they didn't complete the treatment. Well, they walked away because it sucked. Why are you taking them out of the paper? You know what I mean? Like, the point of psychology, again, you know, the second section is to make people effective at doing something, right? And so if you have to throw away everybody who walks away from your
你的模型，那么它就不是很有效。我经常回到荣格那里。我的意思是，比我预期的做这种事情要多得多。但我认为卡尔·荣格和荣格疗法之所以在这一点上，我的意思是，它已经比精神分析更长寿了。就像做荣格心理学的人比做精神分析的人少，尽管荣格心理学可以说也在垂死和消失。有一些机构在做它。有基于它的模型。没有多少东西是基于弗洛伊德派的。只有，我的意思是，我想有一些人技术上是新弗洛伊德派，但他们的想法并没有回到弗洛伊德。你知道，呃，当
model, then it wasn't very effective. And I come back to Jung a lot. I mean, more really than I ever expected to doing something like this. But one of the reasons why I think that Carl Jung and Jungian therapy has kind of exactly, I mean, at this point, it's outlasted psychoanalysis. Like there's less people doing psychoanalysis than are doing Jungian psychology, even though Jungian psychology is still arguably dying and going away. There's like institutes that are doing it. There's models based on it. There's not a lot of stuff based on the Freudians. there's just, I mean, I guess there were people who like were technically Neo Freudian, but their ideas don't go back to Freud. You know, uh, when
你，当你看看像温尼科特（Winnicott），当你看看霍妮（Horney）或安娜·弗洛伊德，他们不是，我在《神经症与人的成长》中看不到任何弗洛伊德的东西。我的意思是，它有点在消亡，或者有点死了，你知道，纽约的几个地方，每个人还在做精神分析，但那只是因为安娜·弗洛伊德去了那里，它会最后在那里消亡，但荣格的东西是一个宇宙观，它是一种现象学的语言，我认为治疗必须是这样的。我的意思是，我不会争论我们需要回到荣格分析中，但我认为这就是为什么人们无法完全摆脱它，是因为我们失去了那个。我的意思是，荣格的东西给了你一个世界观。它给了你一种理解不仅是你自己，而且是你自己
you, when you look at like one, a cot, when you look at horny or an eye, like they weren't, I don't see any Freud in like neurosis and human growth. I mean, it's kind of dying, um, or kind of dead, you know, a couple of places in New York, everybody's still in psychoanalysis, but that's just because Anna Freud went there, and it's going to die there last, but like the Jungian stuff is a cosmology, and it is a language for a phenomenology in a way that I think therapy has to be, like I'm not going to make an argument that we need to go back into Jungian analysis, but I think that's why people can't quite get away from it, is because we lost that. I mean, the Jungian stuff was giving you a worldview. It was giving you a way to understand not only yourself, but the way that yourself
与世界互动的方式，然后使之变得灵活。这就是我认为当人们回去并真正深入研究这个，或者他们，你知道，治疗师在50多岁时服用蘑菇，然后他们决定他们要成为荣格派，他们开始进入这些东西，或者你知道，只是荣格的吸引力，我仍然看到这么多年轻人发现他，然后以一种他们对弗洛伊德没有的方式沉迷于它。你读弗洛伊德是因为你必须读，但他已经是历史了，而你读荣格的方式是他仍然对某些人说话，我认为原因在于，这就是当我谈到“自我”的概念时，我们必须建立一个连贯的意义，即那个词意味着什么以及如何
interacted with the world, and then make that flexible. And that's what I think when people go back and they get really into this, or they, you know, the therapist like takes mushrooms in their 50s, and then they decide that they're going to be a Jungian and they start to get into these things or you know just the appeal of Jung like I still see so many young people discovering him and then getting obsessed with it in a way that they don't with Freud you read Freud because you have to but he's history and you read Jung in a way that he still speaks to certain kinds of people and the reason for that I think is that and this is when I say the idea of self is something that we have to build a coherent sense of what that word means and how
在治疗中应用它，你知道，因为如果你在做行为疗法，对吧，你知道，让我们回到这些术语来源的历史，好吗？你知道，好吧，精神分析，当弗洛伊德开始精神分析时，我的意思是，他所说的是，自我是动态相互作用的产物，本我是原始和本能的，自我是现实主义者或逻辑学家，超我是必须在它们之间做出决定的更大驱动力。他说桌子装饰上有这些乒乓球在咔哒、咔哒、咔哒地响，能量从一个转移到另一个，即使那个可能没有移动，它仍然，你知道，在心理上、物理上连接着。这是一个我认为人们仍然会回到的想法。就像，如果人们回到弗洛伊德那里，
to apply it within therapy, you know, because if you're doing behavioral therapy, right, you know, let's go back to the history of where these terms come from, okay? You know, okay, so psychoanalysis, when Freud starts psychoanalysis, I mean, what he's saying is that the self is this product of dynamic interplay, that the id is primitive and instinctual, the ego is a realist or a logical, a logician, and the superego is a greater drive that must decide between them. And he's saying that there's these kind of ping-pong balls on the desk ornament going click, click, click, and the energy is transferred from one to the other, even though the one may not move, it's still, you know, connected psychically, physically. And that's an idea that I think people still come back to. Like, if people go back to Freud at all,
那就是他们回到的地方。有很多人，你看看像关系精神分析，你看看基督教，我忘了他们叫什么，有一些基于信仰的精神分析的东西，你知道，当你把精神分析带到那个地步时，弗洛伊德的东西就什么都不剩了。
that's what they go back to. There's so many people that, you look at something like relational psychoanalysis, you look at Christian, I forget what they call it, there's some faith-based psychoanalysis thing, which, you know, it's kind of, by the time you take psychoanalysis to that point, there's nothing left of Freud,
这就是他们回归的本质。有很多人，你看像关系精神分析，你看基督教，我忘了他们怎么称呼它，有一种基于信仰的精神分析，你知道，当你把精神分析发展到那种程度时，弗洛伊德的东西就已经荡然无存了。
except the dynamism. That was what people like. I mean, and like maybe repression and projection, you know, but of completely different things and in completely different ways than he would have ever allowed you to go. But it's that dynamic nature of self. And that's why he's still relevant or people, you know feel um that he created something as that was the first time they saw it you know concretely the people who were doing you know the hypnotism or the mesmerism you know before freud they were kind of doing this parlor trick but they didn't articulate a language of the unconscious they were talking about you know a part of the brain cut off or fighting itself or that the neuron wanted to go back to being dead because it came from whatever like and he says no these ping pong balls are whacking each other and the psychology starts so you know if the only good idea that that guy ever had
除了活力。那是人们喜欢的东西。我的意思是，也许还有压抑和投射，你知道，但那是完全不同的事物，以完全不同的方式，远超他所允许你探索的范畴。但这就是自我的动态本质。这就是为什么他至今仍有意义，或者人们觉得他创造了一些东西，那是他们第一次具体地看到它。你知道，在弗洛伊德之前，那些做催眠术或麦斯麦术的人，他们做的更像是某种江湖把戏，但他们没有阐述出一套关于潜意识的语言。他们谈论的是大脑中被切断或自我对抗的部分，或者神经因为源于某种东西而想要回到死亡状态，等等。而他说，不，这些乒乓球在互相撞击，心理学由此开始。所以，如果那个人曾经有过唯一的好主意
is this thing that is something that we're giving up you know isn't even psychology anymore you know jung jung said you, the self is the central archetype. Jung's idea was, no, like the unconscious isn't bad. It's not just this, this thing that has to be dealt with because it produces symptoms. You know, Freud called it the subconscious and Jung said, no, it's not a sub. Um, it's an unconscious. And then, you know, later I think Freud or Jung becomes so enamored with the unconscious that he, maybe he should have called it a Dom, uh, conscious, uh, because he, he seems to eventually view it as sort of more of the point than the conscious, um, which is where a lot of
就是这个我们正在放弃的东西，甚至不再是心理学了。荣格说，自我（self）是核心原型。荣格的观点是，不，潜意识并不坏。它不仅仅是那种因为产生症状而必须处理的东西。你知道，弗洛伊德称之为下意识（subconscious），而荣格说，不，它不是“下”（sub），它是潜意识（unconscious）。然后，你知道，后来我认为弗洛伊德或荣格对潜意识变得如此着迷，以至于他也许应该称之为“主意识”（dom-conscious），因为他最终似乎认为它比意识本身更重要，而这正是很多
people I think lose him, um, because they don't have that deep intuition and respect for those spiritual spaces that he came to see as the point of life, his life. But that, and so his archetypes were different. It was persona and shadow and anima and animus, but there is still this dynamic interplay. I mean, what Jung changes this concept of self is he says, okay, the self is connected to God. And it doesn't have to be God, like aistic Metaphysical God it's this greater concept like he he thought that basically we talked about the unconscious like it was God and maybe it Was he didn't know you know he just thought that there was this place That the self was connected to and the more that you dealt with the ego rigidity the more that you made the unconscious conscious
人我认为失去他的地方，因为他们没有那种深刻的直觉，也没有对他视为生命意义的精神空间的尊重。但他的原型是不同的。那是人格面具、阴影、阿尼玛和阿尼姆斯，但仍然存在这种动态的相互作用。我的意思是，荣格改变的这个自我概念是，他说，好吧，自我与上帝相连。它不一定非要是上帝，那种有神论的形而上学的上帝，它是一个更宏大的概念。他基本上认为我们谈论潜意识就像谈论上帝一样，也许它确实是。他不知道，你知道，他只是认为存在这样一个地方，自我与之相连，你处理自我僵化的问题越多，你将潜意识意识化的程度就越高
the more that you were able to be aware of the functioning of archetypes in your life through symbol and dream and, you know, projection and reintegration and all of that, the more that you were going to have room to embody this, what feels like, because it's so intuitive, you know, and maybe it is, you know, spiritually that way too, this divine mission. So, you know, in the Western Christian tradition, this idea that God is separate from me and then Jesus comes as this intermediary to teach me how to interact with God. That's how Jung saw self, you know, or in the Buddhist tradition, you know, the Buddha comes to teach you how to disband the self in order to really know, um, by disbanding the self, you know, the unconscious or whatever, but it's this, those messianic figures are this bridge. And so he's, when he's saying the word God, a lot of times he's talking about the depth and breath, like the deepest parts of the unconscious. And he disagrees with Freud on the utility of it. You
你越能通过象征、梦境、投射和重整合等方式意识到原型在你生活中的运作，你就越有空间去体现这种感觉——因为它非常直观，你知道，也许在精神上也是如此——这种神圣的使命。所以，在西方基督教传统中，上帝与我分离，然后耶稣作为中介来教我如何与上帝互动。这就是荣格看待自我的方式，或者在佛教传统中，佛陀来教你如何解构自我以真正认识（真理），通过解构自我，你知道，潜意识或其他什么，但这些弥赛亚式的人物就是一座桥梁。所以，当他说“上帝”这个词时，很多时候他谈论的是深度和广度，就像潜意识最深处的部分。他不同意弗洛伊德关于其功用的看法。你
know, he thinks it's the point. Freud is kind of repressing it. So then when you get, like, these newer therapy models, like, I'll take IFS, for example. You know, IFS is, you know, gestalt therapy getting put together with Jung. There's a lot of other influence that he has. You know, Adler's definitely one there, too. I've never heard Schwartz say that, but you can see some of that Larry and stuff. Um, but I'm not saying he hasn't said that. I just haven't read that. Um, but the, uh, that core, um, sense of self and IFS is that there's protective parts that come from trauma
知道，他认为这才是重点。弗洛伊德是在压抑它。所以，当你接触到像IFS（内在家庭系统疗法）这样较新的治疗模型时。你知道，IFS是格式塔疗法与荣格理论的结合。他还有很多其他的影响。你知道，阿德勒绝对也是其中之一。我从未听施瓦茨（Schwartz）这样说过，但你可以看到其中一些拉里（Larry）的东西。嗯，但我不是说他没说过，我只是没读到过。嗯，但是，那个核心的自我感，在IFS中，就是存在源于创伤的保护性部分
and they come from all of these things, but that deep down, we all want to be compassionate. We all want to be curious. We all want to be curious. We all want to be confident. And we all have this sort of mission that motivates us. So it's very much like that divine vulnerable child that in Jungian analysis, when you peel everything off, you remember what you just knew when you were six about who you were, but you forgot it in life because it was beaten out of you by logic or, you know, trauma or whatever.
它们源于所有这些事情，但内心深处，我们都想变得富有同情心。我们都想变得好奇。我们都想变得好奇。我们都想变得自信。我们都有某种激励我们的使命。所以这非常像荣格分析中那个神圣而脆弱的孩子，当你剥离一切，你会想起六岁时你所知道的关于你是谁的一切，但你在生活中忘记了它，因为它被逻辑、创伤或其他什么东西从你身上抹去了。
You know, those are the models of therapy. I like, I like internal family systems. I like somatic experiencing. I like, like lifespan integration, lifespan integration, um, you know, sees the self as these series of moments that are supposed to be on this continuing spectrum, you know, continuum, but that all of a sudden our ego was rigid at these different places. And those places are so separate that they don't understand. You know, I thought in March of 2020 that I was such a different thing that mutually excludes everything that I am now that I don't know how to hold it. And that memory has become fragmented. And that by digging up these rigid ego states as life events, and then using ally techniques to smash them together, you know, we make them
你知道，这些就是治疗模型。我喜欢内在家庭系统疗法。我喜欢躯体体验疗法。我喜欢寿命整合疗法（Lifespan Integration），寿命整合疗法，嗯，你知道，将自我视为一系列应该处于这个连续谱上的时刻，你知道，连续体，但突然间我们的自我（ego）在这些不同的地方僵化了。而这些地方是如此分离，以至于它们互不理解。你知道，我在2020年3月时认为我是一个如此不同的东西，与我现在的一切互不相容，以至于我不知道如何去把握它。而那段记忆变得支离破碎。通过挖掘这些僵化的自我状态作为生活事件，然后使用盟友技术将它们撞击在一起，你知道，我们让它们
crack and then reintegrate, you know. I like those models because I think that that is the kind of sense of self that we have to have. Now what's dangerous are the robot people, the Silicon Valley people. There's plenty of great CBT therapists. I've seen them, but a lot of times those people are going to be more relational and they're just going to have figured out a whole lot of stuff that is helpful. And it doesn't really follow CBT as I'm talking about it. What I'm talking about is a very academic, completely manualized form of CBT where they go back behind you. Like when you do a research study, they go back and they check for competence. They control for competence in a lot of those studies by saying like, did that person follow the manual? You know, when the
破裂然后重整合，你知道。我喜欢这些模型，因为我认为这就是我们必须拥有的那种自我感。现在危险的是那些机器人一样的人，硅谷的那些人。有很多很棒的CBT（认知行为疗法）治疗师。我见过他们，但很多时候这些人会更具关系导向，他们只是弄清楚了很多有用的东西。这并不真正遵循我所谈论的CBT。我所谈论的是一种非常学术的、完全手册化的CBT形式，他们在你身后。就像当你做研究时，他们会回去检查能力。他们在许多研究中通过询问“那个人是否遵循了手册”来控制能力。你知道，当
patient said this, did they say, well, actually that's a cognitive distortion or whatever. Like, and, and so it's, it's more rigid than you're even going to find like in the wild a lot of the time. Um, but they, CBT sees the self as like this cognitive construct that is only composed of everything that you think and you believe. And maybe something that Beck would call like schemas, that the schemas we adopt affect our perceptions and behaviors. So, yeah, you know, it's sometimes in the self, there's these little things that impair logic. paralogic but really we're just this logical creature that is only a product of everything that uh you know i'm thinking in my ego or that i um things that have happened to me and it's the self is malleable in cbt and that like we can be modified through identification and restructuring of maladaptive thought patterns like you can like go in and say, oh, well, you're acting irrationally here.
病人说了这个，他们是否说，嗯，实际上那是一种认知扭曲或其他什么。就像，所以它比你在现实中经常发现的要僵化得多。嗯，但是，CBT将自我视为一种认知结构，仅由你所想和所信的一切组成。也许还有贝克（Beck）所称的图式（schemas），即我们采用的图式会影响我们的感知和行为。所以，是的，你知道，有时在自我中，存在这些损害逻辑的小东西。准逻辑，但实际上我们只是这种逻辑生物，仅仅是我在自我中思考的一切，或者我……发生在我身上的事情的产物。在CBT中，自我具有可塑性，我们可以通过识别和重构适应不良的思维模式来修正它，就像你可以进去说，哦，好吧，你在这里表现得不理性。
So you need to stop. But CBT doesn't even have like a good reason for why other than that there, I mean, I think his language is that kind of like Anna Freudian ego defenses that the ego just doesn't want to have anxiety. So it does something illogical. But I just, I hate that.
所以你需要停止。但CBT甚至没有一个好的理由，除了……我的意思是，我认为他的语言是那种安娜·弗洛伊德式的自我防御，即自我只是不想产生焦虑。所以它做了一些不合逻辑的事情。但我只是，我讨厌那样。
I like, I really think that that is so limiting and stupid. Um, when it's taken in the vacuum that academia wants to put it in, if you do CBT, if you like CBT, we all do some CBT. We all do some psychoeducation. I'm not saying that that thing is terrible or it makes you a bad clinician. I'm saying that doing nothing but that in the way that they teach it, I think does make you a bad clinician, you know. Something like ABA, which is, you know, the gold standard, according to research for the treatment of autism is incredibly offensive to me. I mean, it's saying that the self is just a collection of learned behaviors that we've taken in from the environment, and they can be reinforced or be punished um which yeah you know i used to just be alone like people would act like you were crazy if you
我喜欢，我真的认为那太局限且愚蠢了。嗯，当它被放在学术界想要放置的真空中时。如果你做CBT，如果你喜欢CBT，我们都做一些CBT。我们都做一些心理教育。我不是说那个东西很糟糕或者它让你成为一个糟糕的临床医生。我是说，只做那个，按照他们教的方式，我认为确实会让你成为一个糟糕的临床医生，你知道。像ABA（应用行为分析）这样的东西，你知道，根据研究是治疗自闭症的黄金标准，对我来说极其冒犯。我的意思是，它说自我只是一系列从环境中习得的行为，它们可以被强化或惩罚。嗯，是的，你知道，我过去只是独自一人，就像人们会表现得好像你疯了一样，如果你
didn't like aba well now i'm watching people get bullied off linkedin and like upload things in tears and i mean i honestly feel bad for them because that's probably just somebody who went to school and was told by a professor well this is this thing that's wonderful that can help people with autism. And then you go upload your, you know, tick talk about it and all of these zoomers are yelling at you that you're treating people like dogs and like, yeah, I mean, you kind of are when you're just doing behaviorism, but, um, like, yeah, like inherent in that model, it's some icky stuff, you know, that the self is just this distinct entity that, well, it's not even a distinct entity.
不喜欢ABA。好吧，现在我看着人们在领英（LinkedIn）上被霸凌，上传视频时泪流满面，我的意思是，我真的为他们感到难过，因为那可能只是一个去上学，被教授告知“这是一个美妙的东西，可以帮助自闭症患者”的人。然后你去上传你的，你知道，关于它的TikTok，所有的Z世代都在对你大喊大叫，说你在像对待狗一样对待人，而且，是的，我的意思是，当你只是在做行为主义时，你确实有点像，但是，嗯，就像，是的，那个模型中固有的，是一些令人不快的东西，你知道，自我只是这个独特的实体，好吧，它甚至不是一个独特的实体。
It's just this product of an individual's behavior history and their current environment. And when you're measuring their change, it doesn't matter how they feel. It doesn't matter how much suffering they're in. It matters, are they doing the thing that you told them to do? I mean, that's not good. To have, like, that is a direction, that if we take the self in that direction, you're trying to turn people into robots by saying that we can just be programmed. And I think that's incredibly offensive. And that there's something probably going on wrong with you.
它只是一个个体行为历史及其当前环境的产物。当你衡量他们的变化时，他们的感受并不重要。他们承受了多少痛苦并不重要。重要的是，他们是否在做你告诉他们要做的事情？我的意思是，那不好。拥有，就像，那是一个方向，如果我们把自我带向那个方向，你就是在试图通过说我们可以被编程来把人变成机器人。我认为这极其冒犯。而且你身上可能确实出了什么问题。
Not saying you're a bad person, but if you believe that, I think that you have a lot of trauma. I don't know how you couldn't, you know, because there's something in me that feels like that is limiting. And I believe that that, and again, this is my concept of self as a therapist, I believe that thing is in everyone, but that other people have various levels of communication with it and contact with it and ability to feel it, you know, and intuitive people, I think, are sort of gaslit about it, or they want to hide it, or they, but also they're proud of it on this other level, you know, they have almost the opposite insecurities of a different type of personality.
不是说你是个坏人，但如果你相信这一点，我认为你有很多创伤。我不知道你怎么可能没有，你知道，因为我内心深处有一种感觉，觉得那是有限制的。我相信，而且再次强调，这是我作为治疗师的自我概念，我相信那个东西在每个人身上都有，但其他人对它的沟通、接触和感受能力处于不同水平，你知道，直觉强的人，我认为，关于这一点被煤气灯效应（gaslit）了，或者他们想隐藏它，或者他们，但同时他们在另一个层面上为它感到自豪，你知道，他们拥有的不安全感几乎与另一种人格类型相反。
You know, like, the idea of something like gestalt therapy, where it's more of an energy that the self is this constantly evolving thing that's always striving for integration and self-actualization, but we can't really label it. We just sort of know when we're there. I think that language is healthy. I mean, there's some times where Jungian and stuff gets so literal, even though I like the theory. It's like, what are we talking about anymore?
你知道，就像，像格式塔疗法这样的东西，它更像是一种能量，即自我是一个不断进化的东西，总是努力实现整合和自我实现，但我们无法真正给它贴上标签。我们只是在到达那里时知道。我认为这种语言是健康的。我的意思是，有时荣格的东西变得太字面化了，尽管我喜欢这个理论。就像，我们到底在谈论什么？
I mean, we can't fit all of these things from the unconscious into language in the way that modern, um, you know, Jungian analysts try and do it. Like, I think sometimes we just have to sit with them and feel them and, and, and, um, and learn to, to feel them move. You know, when people were saying, well, what do you mean about this boat metaphor at the end of the last part? What I mean is that there's a way to feel something without labeling it. And our ego doesn't know that if I don't know the name for it, if I can't tell you about it,
我的意思是，我们无法像现代，嗯，你知道，荣格分析师试图做的那样，把潜意识里的所有这些东西都塞进语言里。就像，我认为有时我们只需要与它们坐在一起，感受它们，并且，并且，嗯，并且学会去感受它们的流动。你知道，当人们说，好吧，你上一部分结尾说的那个船的隐喻是什么意思？我的意思是，有一种方法可以在不贴标签的情况下感受某物。而我们的自我（ego）不知道，如果我不知道它的名字，如果我不能告诉你关于它的一切，
it's not real. And, and that isn't true. There are things that I cannot tell you about, not because I won't, but because I don't really understand them yet, but I know that they're there. I mean, if you go do something like brain spotting, if you go come to Taproot and try, you know, something like, um, you know, SLT, like, or ETT therapy, if you're anywhere in Texas, please go try ETT therapy because it's everywhere there. You feel these things happening in your sub brain that are part of you, but you don't know what they are and you can't even really say it. And then you feel yourself changing, you know, the idea that the self can change is like an idea that we can't lose, um, in therapy. And also that the idea that the self is dynamic. I mean, if you don't want to go all the way through the Jungian stuff, that the self is, you know,
它就不是真实的。而那不是真的。有些事情我无法告诉你，不是因为我不想，而是因为我还没有真正理解它们，但我知道它们在那里。我的意思是，如果你去做像脑点疗法（brain spotting）这样的事情，如果你去Taproot尝试，你知道，像，嗯，你知道，SLT，或者ETT疗法，如果你在德克萨斯州的任何地方，请去尝试ETT疗法，因为它在那里随处可见。你感觉到这些事情在你的潜大脑中发生，它们是你的一部分，但你不知道它们是什么，甚至无法真正说出来。然后你感觉到自己在改变，你知道，自我可以改变这个想法是我们在治疗中不能失去的想法。还有自我具有动态性这个想法。我的意思是，如果你不想完全深入荣格的东西，即自我，你知道，
this connection to this divine God or divine purpose that we find when we get our ego out of the way and we're able to listen. I don't think you have to. I don't think that kind of therapy is what everybody wants. But if you want to say that the self isn't there, that we're just behavior and cognition, I mean, that's terrifying. And if you want to say that the self can't change, I think that's scary. And if you want to say that the self is just, um, you know, this thing that symptoms pop up around and then we weed them out, but there's no relationship to the symptoms. The unconscious is just the source of bad things that we can go through and clear out and get rid of.
这种与神圣上帝或神圣目的的连接，当我们把自我（ego）移开并能够倾听时，我们就会发现。我不认为你必须这样做。我不认为那种治疗是每个人都想要的。但如果你想说自我不存在，我们只是行为和认知，我的意思是，那太可怕了。如果你想说自我不能改变，我认为那很吓人。如果你想说自我只是，嗯，你知道，症状在周围冒出来，然后我们把它们除掉，但与症状没有关系的东西。潜意识只是坏事的来源，我们可以经历并清除掉它们。
Um, like we're cutting the grass that they're the roots of them. Don't go deep inside of that thing and feed off of it and have a purpose. If we don't view our internal world like an ecosystem in psychology, that's scary. And I mean, that's one of the reasons why I think people were like, well, what kind of therapist should I find?
嗯，就像我们在割草，它们是草根。不要深入那个东西并从中汲取养分并拥有目的。如果我们不在心理学中把我们的内心世界看作一个生态系统，那很可怕。我的意思是，这就是为什么我认为人们会问，好吧，我应该找什么样的治疗师。
I don't think it matters. I'm sure there's people out there doing brain spotting that are terrible. As far as modality, I don't think it matters, but there's things you should look at. And one of them is the ability to reflect, to have these conversations and not say, oh no, no, this is it. You know, to be open to a lot of different models, to be interested, to be curious. I mean, these are the marks of like an ego that has good healthy boundaries. I mean, honestly, one thing is like, I think that you should find a therapist that's funny, um, or, or somebody that can laugh at themselves because you know,
我不认为这很重要。我相信外面有人在做脑点疗法，但他们很糟糕。就模式而言，我不认为这很重要，但有些事情你应该关注。其中之一是反思的能力，能够进行这些对话，而不是说，哦不，不，就是这样。你知道，要对许多不同的模型保持开放，要感兴趣，要好奇。我的意思是，这些是一个拥有良好健康边界的自我（ego）的标志。我的意思是，老实说，有一件事是，我认为你应该找一个有趣的治疗师，嗯，或者一个能自嘲的人，因为你知道，
where the shadow is there. Like, you know, humor is this kind of alchemical process where it's this benign attack where we take all these things that we either can't change, or we don't want someone to know, or we know that they don't want to know. And then we make it into this weapon to hit them over the head with it. But then we make the weapon silly where it doesn't really hurt them but it still feels like an attack i mean that's that's what you're doing with humor is you're taking language and you're weaponizing it and then you're pulling your punch you know tickling right like it feels like i'm being attacked but i know i'm not um there's this benign attack theory of humor that's kind of replacing the older humor the older
阴影在哪里。就像，你知道，幽默是一种炼金过程，它是一种良性的攻击，我们把所有那些我们要么无法改变，要么不想让别人知道，或者我们知道他们不想知道的事情拿出来。然后我们把它变成一种武器去敲他们的头。但随后我们让武器变得愚蠢，它并没有真正伤害他们，但它仍然感觉像是一种攻击。我的意思是，这就是你用幽默所做的，你正在利用语言并将其武器化，然后你收回了拳头，你知道，挠痒痒，对吧？就像它感觉像是我被攻击了，但我知道我没有。嗯，有一种幽默的良性攻击理论，它正在取代旧的幽默，旧的
theories about humor's surprise and things and somebody who can do that is generally comfortable enough to deal with uncertainty you know uh which is really what you want because when you're going into a process where the self has to change you can't have certainty. You know, no one can tell you on day two or year three of Jungian analysis how it's going to end because it's about dealing, making room for uncertainty so that you can feel who you are authentically, so the next thing that is something that I think therapy has to come to a conversation with, and I think we come to an understanding with any of these. I think we're always trying to hit a moving target by understanding these things in therapy. The first one was self.
关于幽默惊喜的理论，而能够做到这一点的人通常足够舒适去处理不确定性，你知道，嗯，这确实是你想要的，因为当你进入一个自我必须改变的过程时，你不能拥有确定性。你知道，没有人能在荣格分析的第二天或第三年告诉你它将如何结束，因为它关乎处理，为不确定性腾出空间，这样你才能真实地感受到你是谁。所以，下一件事是我认为治疗必须进行对话的，而且我认为我们与其中任何一个都能达成理解。我认为我们在治疗中总是试图通过理解这些东西来击中一个移动的目标。第一个是自我。
And the next one is this idea of implicit memory. And to connect those, I'll give you this example of like, when you look at an eye in the back of your eye, in the middle of it, you know, like the retinal cells that see the picture, there's not room for them in the very middle. But the reason there's not room for them in the middle is because, sorry, my chair's breaking and clicking and I can't afford another one. So it's really loud. Uh, but the reason that it's like clicking, um, and I'm not, not the chair clicking. Um, the reason that you can't see out of that spot in the center of your eye is because all those blood vessels come through it. Um, and there's, and the nerve
下一个是内隐记忆（implicit memory）这个概念。为了连接这些，我给你举这个例子，就像，当你看着眼睛的后部，在它的中间，你知道，就像看到图像的视网膜细胞，在最中间没有空间给它们。但中间没有空间的原因是因为，抱歉，我的椅子在断裂和咔哒作响，我买不起另一把。所以它真的很吵。嗯，但是它像咔哒作响的原因，嗯，不是椅子在咔哒作响。嗯，你无法从眼睛中心的那个点看到东西的原因是因为所有的血管都穿过它。嗯，而且有，神经
endings. And so there's no way to put, um, like on the retinal coating, there's no room for the, like retina to, you can't put the nerve cell right on the, um, lens cause they are right on the nerve and the, uh, entrance to the blood vessels because, uh, they break up the surface you know it's not the perfect lens yeah so what you see in the middle of your eye you don't actually see your brain is basically running a Photoshop filter all the time even if you just see something out of one eye and you don't have the binocularity of the other one to like fill in that hole so like the thing in the center of your perception that you're looking at a lot of the time when you're, you know, pupils lined up straight with that, um, point is like just a guess that your brain is making based on this other information. Okay. So it's not actually
末梢。所以没有办法放置，嗯，就像在视网膜涂层上，没有空间给，就像视网膜，你不能把神经细胞直接放在，嗯，晶状体上，因为它们就在神经上，而且，嗯，血管的入口，因为，嗯，它们破坏了表面，你知道，它不是完美的晶状体。是的，所以你在眼睛中间看到的东西，你实际上并没有看到，你的大脑基本上一直在运行Photoshop滤镜，即使你只是用一只眼睛看东西，而没有另一只眼睛的双眼视觉来填补那个洞。所以，就像你感知中心的东西，当你，你知道，瞳孔与那个点对齐时，你看着的很多时候，就像只是你的大脑基于这些其他信息做出的猜测。好吧。所以它实际上不是
like a thing. Um, there's always this processing that is happening deep down for you to make a guess. I'm like a lot of the problems with vision, when you start to lose your vision in the middle of your eye, have to do with those algorithms and the way that that signal is being processed, sort of breaking so that it's not done quite right. You know, you get a black hole in your vision. So, I mean, that image, I think, takes this idea of self, which is like who the patient is right slash was slash will be you can't leave the present or the past out of this idea of self um and also like I don't even think you can talk about it without language that sounds sort of religious like that um I think
像一个东西。嗯，总是有这种处理在深处发生，让你做出猜测。我，就像视觉的很多问题，当你开始失去眼睛中间的视力时，都与那些算法以及信号被处理的方式有关，某种程度上坏掉了，所以它没有做得完全正确。你知道，你的视野中出现了一个黑洞。所以，我的意思是，那个图像，我认为，采用了这个自我概念，即病人是谁，现在/曾经/将来会是谁。你不能把现在或过去从这个自我概念中剔除。而且，就像，我甚至认为你不能在没有语言的情况下谈论它，那听起来有点像宗教，那种……我认为
that there is a kind of inevitable quality to what we are, even if that's totally a secular material concept. When you're talking about these people that like change throughout their whole life over time and like don't quite know who they are, you know. It's like what Heraclitus, the Greek philosopher, he says like mankind can never step in the same river twice because when you go back and you step in that river again all the water is left that you stepped in the first time and you're actually stepping in a new river you may call it the Thames Thames or whatever but it's actually you know a new thing that's that's always being born um that we kind of need to have that conception of who we were who we we are, where we're going, inherent in the model of therapy that we're doing. And if the model of therapy doesn't have that built into it, I would be scared of it. You know, like what is it, the Greek mystery cults where
我们是什么有一种不可避免的特质，即使那完全是一个世俗的物质概念。当你谈论这些在整个生命中随时间变化，并且不太知道自己是谁的人时，你知道。就像赫拉克利特，那位希腊哲学家，他说，人类永远无法两次踏入同一条河流，因为当你回去再次踏入那条河时，所有的水都已经流走了，你第一次踏入时，你实际上是在踏入一条新的河流。你可能称它为泰晤士河或什么，但它实际上，你知道，是一个总是被诞生的新事物。我们需要对我们曾经是谁、我们是谁、我们要去哪里有那种概念，这在我们正在做的治疗模型中是固有的。如果治疗模型中没有内置这一点，我会对它感到害怕。你知道，就像它是什么，希腊神秘崇拜，在那里
they're trying to like strip your identity away and make you ask these deeper questions and be in touch with this and like one of the rituals you go through and some they would yell these questions at you and you're walking across a bridge and somebody yells you know who are you you're like i'm you know a greek name and then and then they're like what are you you're like I'm a human I'm a Greek I'm a Christian I'm a in the cult of Diana I'm you know you you have to come up with some way of labeling who you are as being part of a group or not part of a group something of reference to something else.
他们试图剥离你的身份，让你问这些更深层的问题，并与此保持联系。就像你经历的仪式之一，在一些仪式中，他们会对着你大喊这些问题，你正走过一座桥，有人大喊，你知道你是谁吗？你说，我是，你知道，一个希腊名字。然后，然后他们说，你是什么？你说，我是人类，我是希腊人，我是基督徒，我是戴安娜崇拜的成员，我是……你知道，你必须想出某种方式来标记你是谁，作为群体的一部分或不是群体的一部分，某种参考其他东西的东西。
And then they would be like, where are you going? Or, you know, these bigger questions. And the first question is usually easy to answer, we think. And then the second question makes us wonder if we answered the first question right. And then the third question makes us wonder what the question is, you know. And if it fails that test, you know, um, and if it fails that test, you know, if, if it, what am I on behavior?
然后他们会说，你要去哪里？或者，你知道，这些更大的问题。第一个问题通常很容易回答，我们认为。然后第二个问题让我们怀疑我们是否正确回答了第一个问题。然后第三个问题让我们怀疑问题是什么，你知道。如果它没通过那个测试，你知道，嗯，如果它没通过那个测试，你知道，如果，如果它，我在行为上处于什么位置？
Where am I going to different behavior? You know, what, what, uh, who am I? I am just a cognition and behavior making organic thing. That's a sad answer. You know, I would, I would put the therapy model through, um, the, the test of these mystery cults and see if it actually can do it. Um, so that as a bridge to this idea of implicit memory, what you see now in academic publishing is people talking about implicit memory or primary, secondary, and tertiary types of memory. And, you know, going all the way back to Jung and Freud and whatever, you know, Freud says the subconscious is just this trash can, all of the sex and violence that we're feeling all the time. Um, we can't express because civilization has made us repress it yet. It is natural yet.
我要去什么不同的行为？你知道，什么，嗯，我是谁？我只是一个认知和行为制造的有机体。那是一个悲伤的答案。你知道，我会把治疗模型通过，嗯，这些神秘崇拜的测试，看看它是否真的能做到。所以，作为通往内隐记忆这个概念的桥梁，你现在在学术出版物中看到的是人们谈论内隐记忆，或者初级、二级和三级记忆类型。而且，你知道，一直追溯到荣格和弗洛伊德等等，你知道，弗洛伊德说潜意识只是这个垃圾桶，所有我们一直感受到的性和暴力。嗯，我们无法表达，因为文明让我们压抑它，然而它是自然的。然而
Our logic now says that it is immoral. Um, and so, you know, that's what is down there. Then Jung says, no, it's different. He sees Freud as somebody who's extremely extroverted sensing and is kind of dealing with that. Um, his shadow is involved a lot with sex and violence. And then, you know, Alfred Adler, Jung saw as someone who was an introvert and a thinker who was, his shadow had more to do with relationship. And that was what was scary to him, or that was what, you know,
我们现在的逻辑说它是不道德的。所以，你知道，这就是在那里的东西。然后荣格说，不，它不同。他把弗洛伊德看作是一个极其外向感觉型的人，正在处理那个问题。嗯，他的阴影与性和暴力有很多关联。然后，你知道，阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒，荣格看作是一个内向者和思想家，他的阴影与关系有更多关系。而那对他来说是可怕的，或者那是，你知道，
these kind of balance of powers and where people get their implicit assumptions about the world. You know, so the unconscious is what we used to call something like implicit memory. But the thing is we're forgetting that the point of therapy isn't what we know. You may need some cognitive retraining. You may need some budgeting advice. You may need a second opinion. You may need some psychoeducation about just the effect of what addiction looks like and that you're not the only person that feels this way and that this is what you do. I mean, you may, yes, there is conscious and intellectual stuff in therapy.
这种权力平衡，以及人们从哪里获得关于世界的内隐假设。你知道，所以潜意识就是我们过去称之为内隐记忆的东西。但问题是，我们忘记了治疗的重点不是我们知道什么。你可能需要一些认知重训练。你可能需要一些预算建议。你可能需要第二意见。你可能需要一些关于成瘾看起来是什么样子的心理教育，以及你不是唯一一个有这种感觉的人，这就是你所做的。我的意思是，你可能，是的，治疗中有意识和理智的东西。
But the point of it really, especially the point of it now, is this thing has become so expensive as we've become like in a world that is just traumatizing the shit out of us all the time to where, you know, people are coming into my office that have like strong dissociative disorders and PTSD, CPTSD, and they don't even think that they have any trauma. And then, you know, I don't fight with them about it. I'm not going to say like, oh, actually, you know, we have this diagnosis. I just like let your eye do the talking. Like when you go and you have a completely disembodyied experience on the ETT light device
但它的重点真的，尤其是现在的重点，是这个东西变得如此昂贵，因为我们生活在一个不断地把我们折磨得要死的世界上，以至于，你知道，人们走进我的办公室，他们有强烈的解离性障碍和PTSD、CPTSD，他们甚至不认为自己有任何创伤。然后，你知道，我不和他们争论。我不会说，哦，实际上，你知道，我们有这个诊断。我只是让你的眼睛说话。就像当你去并在ETT光设备上
or doing SLT or doing brain spotting, and all of a sudden you relive all this stuff and you see how much it was controlling the muscles in your back and that I couldn't even put my hand up this high because I was always trying to keep my arm down to protect myself. All these things built into our somatic memory and all of that. Like, yeah, you had cptsd man like you're you that actually had more of an effect on you than you know and your ego is saying but it's not affecting the way that i'm thinking
或做SLT或做脑点疗法时，你完全经历了一种脱离身体的体验，突然间你重温了所有这些东西，你看到它在多大程度上控制了你背部的肌肉，以至于我甚至不能把手举得这么高，因为我总是试图把手臂放低来保护自己。所有这些东西都内置在我们的躯体记忆中，所有这些。就像，是的，你有CPTSD，伙计，就像你，那实际上对你的影响比你知道的要大，而你的自我（ego）在说，但这并没有影响我的思考方式
but it is affecting your body and it is affecting the way that you feel and that is affecting the way that you think you know we want to protect ourselves you know me like listen to the last episode like by maybe being like i don't like the word intellectual but by feeling like there is no perspective that we don't understand like across history or whatever and like yes of course that's a reaction to pain and powerlessness and like all of the stuff in every therapist background the good ones just know how to admit that the bad ones don't not have it. And no, they didn't go to therapy for six years and now they're better. And now they know how to tell you how to get better. Like, you know, it implicit memory is such an important thing because what it is, is the set
但它确实在影响你的身体，它在影响你的感受，而那正在影响你的思考方式。你知道，我们想保护自己，你知道我，就像听上一集一样，通过也许像，我不喜欢“理智”这个词，但通过感觉好像没有我们不理解的视角，跨越历史或其他什么。而且，是的，当然那是对痛苦和无力感的反应，以及每个治疗师背景中的所有东西，好的治疗师只是知道如何承认这一点，坏的治疗师没有它。而且不，他们没有去接受六年的治疗，现在他们变好了。现在他们知道如何告诉你如何变好。就像，你知道，内隐记忆是一件如此重要的事情，因为它是什么，是
of assumptions that our body, our deep brain is like making all the time and it is moving faster. It is processing information so much faster than the front of our brain. Even when we're frantic, even when we're like trying to think, um, of like all of these things to do and like be highly effective, your brainstem is moving. I don't remember exactly what it is, the study that I read. so I'm not going to look it up, but it's moving like, you know, five or six times as fast when you look at information processing. It's not like Hertz, like a CPU, but when you look at how much information it is processing, it is moving faster than the front of your brain because it's reacting to all this stuff
我们的身体、我们的深层大脑一直在做出的假设集合，而且它移动得更快。它处理信息的速度比我们大脑的前部快得多。即使当我们疯狂时，即使当我们试图思考，嗯，所有这些要做的事情并试图变得高效时，你的脑干也在移动。我不记得确切是什么了，我读过的研究。所以我不会去查它，但它移动得像，你知道，五六倍快，当你观察信息处理时。它不像赫兹，像CPU，但当你观察它处理了多少信息时，它比你的大脑前部移动得更快，因为它在对所有这些东西做出反应
that you don't even have time to think about. So of course it's going faster. You know, am I afraid of the man in the red sweater? Like, do I need to keep my posture like this because I'm trying to be powerful and sexual? Or do I need to keep my posture like this because I don't want to be noticed? Or if somebody calls my name and says, hey, John, like, am I going to go, um, yeah, yeah, what's up? Who's there? i'm happy to see anybody or am i gonna go oh somebody sees me that's bad what do i you know all of that information you can't even think about it because your body has to know it before you could make a conscious decision so like of course it's going faster and like that's why i think but then at the same time you can ignore that and pretend
你甚至没有时间去思考。所以当然它移动得更快。你知道，我害怕那个穿红毛衣的人吗？就像，我需要保持这样的姿势吗，因为我试图变得强大和性感？或者我需要保持这样的姿势吗，因为我不想被注意到？或者如果有人叫我的名字说，嘿，约翰，就像，我会说，嗯，是的，是的，怎么了？谁在那里？我很高兴见到任何人，还是我会说，哦，有人看到我了，那很糟糕，我该怎么办，你知道，所有这些信息你甚至无法思考，因为你的身体必须在你做出有意识的决定之前就知道它。所以，当然它移动得更快，而且，这就是为什么我认为，但同时你可以忽略这一点并假装
that's not real oh no i just got mad you just scared me i just haven't eaten today i'm whatever no man we've lived in the same house like your body is always doing this you are always acting like something is about to hit you and when somebody comes out and shares something with you that is like unexpected then you immediately get upset because you view the unexpected and the uncertain as a threat to you. And then you react with hostility to the person that brought it up, you know, whatever, there's a million relationship dynamics, but this is what therapy is about in a way that like, even these newer models that are like trauma, trauma, trauma seem to have forgotten that this is what it is, that it's not what the person's saying. It's why they're that it's not what the person's saying.
那不是真的。哦不，我只是生气了，你只是吓到我了，我今天只是没吃东西，我只是什么……不，伙计，我们住在同一个房子里，就像你的身体一直在做这个。你总是表现得好像有什么东西要撞到你一样，当有人出来并与你分享一些意想不到的事情时，你立刻就会心烦意乱，因为你把意想不到和不确定性视为对你的威胁。然后你对提出它的人表现出敌意，你知道，无论如何，有数百万种关系动态，但这就是治疗的意义所在，以至于即使这些像创伤、创伤、创伤这样较新的模型似乎也忘记了这就是它，它不是那个人在说什么。它是为什么他们……它不是那个人在说什么。
It's why they're saying it. It's not even what they're feeling. It's why they're saying that thing. Why do I have this image of myself this way? Why do I have this image of the world? How is my body holding that? I mean, when a real, I really hope she can come on the podcast because she's so good. But one of the physical therapists that we work with in Birmingham, she's not at Taproot, but we refer a lot of trauma patients to her and she does pelvic floor work. And, you know, she's like, how can you look at somebody's eye and know what they're doing? You know, what, know how to, you know, pull them through this trauma or whatever. And it's like, well, their eye looks here every single time they say they feel trapped with mom and then they get
它是为什么他们在说它。甚至不是他们在感受什么。它是为什么他们在说那件事。为什么我以这种方式拥有自己的形象？为什么我有这个世界的形象？我的身体是如何保持那个的？我的意思是，当一个真正的，我真的希望她能来播客，因为她太棒了。但我们在伯明翰合作的一位物理治疗师，她不在Taproot，但我们把很多创伤病人转诊给她，她做盆底工作。而且，你知道，她说，你怎么能看着某人的眼睛就知道他们在做什么？你知道，什么，知道如何，你知道，引导他们度过这个创伤或其他什么。就像，嗯，他们的眼睛每次说他们觉得被妈妈困住时都会看这里，然后他们变得
overwhelmed and I see their posture do this. And then I don't even have to look for the brain spot anymore I just know to go there but she's like Erin you know she's like how can you do that I'm like how can you just touch someone's back I mean because I have these patients who you know like they're you know strong powerful people who don't you know that you can't cold read them like they are extremely successful yet they have these you know episodes of dissociation or whatever and Erin will just touch them and be like you know i feel like there's a little boy that's like six or seven and muscles right here why don't your body doesn't like this posture i can tell i'm getting a jerk off of it why don't you just go into this position and like move them into this position and then so many of them have said that their first session is this that she they were feeling fine they were like yeah fine
不知所措，我看到他们的姿势变成这样。然后我甚至不需要再寻找脑点了，我只是知道去那里。但她说，艾琳（Erin），你知道，她说，你怎么能做到？我说，你怎么能只是触摸某人的背？我的意思是，因为我有这些病人，你知道，就像他们是，你知道，强大有力的人，他们不，你知道，你不能冷读他们，就像他们非常成功，但他们有这些，你知道，解离发作或其他什么。艾琳会只是触摸他们并说，你知道，我觉得有一个六七岁的小男孩，肌肉就在这里，为什么你的身体不喜欢这个姿势，我能感觉到我从中得到了一个抽搐，为什么你不只是进入这个位置，就像把他们移动到这个位置，然后他们中的许多人说，他们的第一次治疗就是这个，他们感觉很好，他们就像，是的，很好
I'll get in the field position I'll get whatever and she just put their body in a way and pressed on their back in a way that they cried for 30 minutes and that was the first physical therapy and that's why I think we were very integrative at taproot not everybody needs physical therapy that has trauma that's not what I mean but But their body remembers this stuff. I mean, you look at like people talking about the body remembering things semantically. Like you look at Jung talking about the unconscious, that these things show up as symbols because you can't know them. Like you can't know.
我会进入胎儿姿势，我会进入任何姿势，她只是把他们的身体放在一个位置，并以一种让他们哭了30分钟的方式按压他们的背部，那是第一次物理治疗。这就是为什么我认为我们在Taproot非常整合，并不是每个有创伤的人都需要物理治疗，我不是那个意思，但是他们的身体记得这些东西。我的意思是，你看看像人们谈论身体在语义上记住事情。就像你看着荣格谈论潜意识，这些东西作为象征出现，因为你无法知道它们。就像你无法知道。
You can't even if you tell somebody, even if you point it out, you can't know. You can think about it you can analyze it but you can't know in the present oh i'm making all these assumptions 200 million times faster than my brain can even like think in language so i'm going to move my shoulder this way like you can't the way that those traumas affect you are as like dreams your relationship to art your relationship to your mythology, which now, you know, for a lot of young people is like video games and, and, and, you know, their trauma informs like how, and their attempt to heal themselves gets them into these kind of fantastical worlds where they're talking about these concepts through symbolism. And we have to come to an understanding in therapy that
你无法，即使你告诉某人，即使你指出来，你无法知道。你可以思考它，你可以分析它，但你无法在当下知道，哦，我正在做出所有这些假设，比我的大脑甚至能用语言思考的速度快2亿倍，所以我打算这样移动我的肩膀。就像你不能，那些创伤影响你的方式就像梦境，你与艺术的关系，你与神话的关系，现在，你知道，对于很多年轻人来说，就像电子游戏，而且，而且，你知道，他们的创伤影响了像如何，以及他们治愈自己的尝试把他们带入了这些幻想世界，在那里他们通过象征主义谈论这些概念。我们必须在治疗中达成一种理解，即
like the unconscious is, it's not like, oh, you know, Jung was wrong. He was a pseudoscientist, but now I'm a brilliant genius who has discovered tertiary memory, which is a level of cognition that is beneath the second level. But also no, like implicit memory, what your brainstem is doing, like is the point of therapy kind of. I mean, maybe the point of a healthy life, of learning to be effective, you know? And I think what trips us up is that we all gravitate when we're talking about things like the unconscious or the implicit memory or somatic reactions to the language that we like. And the somatic experiencing person goes to Peter Levin or Pat Ogden and they're like, oh yeah, like the way that I'm sensing this in my body, I'm judging the experience, but really I need to just be with it and accept it.
潜意识是，它不是，哦，你知道，荣格错了。他是一个伪科学家，但现在我是一个天才，发现了三级记忆，这是低于第二层级的认知水平。但同时不，就像内隐记忆，你的脑干正在做的事情，就像是治疗的重点。我的意思是，也许是健康生活的重点，学习变得高效，你知道？而且我认为让我们绊倒的是，当我们谈论像潜意识或内隐记忆或躯体反应这样的事情时，我们都倾向于我们喜欢的语言。而躯体体验的人去找彼得·莱文（Peter Levin）或帕特·奥格登（Pat Ogden），他们说，哦，是的，就像我在身体中感知这个的方式，我在评判这种体验，但实际上我只需要与它在一起并接受它。
And instead of pushing it away from me, I need to suck it up inside of me. And then the intuitive feeler person goes to Jung and says, Oh, wow, it's the king archetype. I don't want to hold authority. I want to get away from the authority. So I need to make myself stand up tall like a king and put the crown on my head. And what I'm telling the person that they actually they have to pay me more because I deserve And when I'm telling the person that they actually, they have to pay me more because I deserve it. Cause I'm a big professional on the phone. I'm going to pretend to hold the scepter and my body will embody this mythological archetype. And that will give me in. And, and then the, you know, the cognitive behavioral person is like, you know, write down the feeling a hundred times. And then we'll start to notice that every evening at sundown, you write down anxiety or some word that's bad. So you have
与其把它推开，我需要把它吸纳进我的内心。然后，直觉型的人会去找荣格，说：“噢，哇，这是国王原型。我不想掌握权力，我想远离权力。”所以我需要让自己像国王一样站得笔直，把王冠戴在头上。当我告诉对方他们实际上必须付给我更多钱，因为我值得的时候，当我告诉对方他们实际上必须付给我更多钱，因为我值得的时候，因为我在电话里是个大人物，我会假装拿着权杖，我的身体会体现出这个神话原型。那会给我带来……然后，你知道，认知行为疗法的人会说，把这种感觉写下来一百遍。然后我们就会开始注意到，每天傍晚日落时，你都会写下“焦虑”或者某个糟糕的词。所以你会有
diarrheal depression and, um, you know, like you're getting depressed before bed. We've, we've found the frequency, intensity, and duration at every different time of day. And yeah, I mean, there's a million different languages, the schema therapy, like, uh, yes. Uh, what, what, I guess one of the ways that psychoanalysis is still around is coherence therapy. That's an interesting one. It's like a time-limited version of psychoanalysis, which is an interesting concept. But yeah, all of these things are using a different language to talk about the way that the base of your brainstem holds memory. And those are these implicit reactions. And they're not just the Bessel van der Kolke,
腹泻式的抑郁，嗯，你知道，就像你在睡前感到抑郁一样。我们已经找到了在一天中不同时间的频率、强度和持续时间。是的，我的意思是，有上百万种不同的语言，比如图式疗法，是的。嗯，我想精神分析之所以还能存在，其中一种方式是相干疗法。那很有趣。它就像是精神分析的限时版本，这是一个有趣的概念。但确实，所有这些东西都在用不同的语言来谈论你的脑干底部保存记忆的方式。而那些就是这些内隐反应。它们不仅仅是贝塞尔·范德考克的，
the body keeps the score, these places in the body. And they're also not like just the Jungian mythological, your relationship to the world and how you conceive of the self and how that interacts with other people. They are a reflection of both of those together, right? Like they are the way that that ball is bouncing back and forth. Like who I am internally is reacting to this outside world externally. Um, and like the thing that I feel in my body is also a symbol. Um, one of the weirder models of therapy that I think was one, the cream doesn't always rise to the top when you look at what's the most popular but look up process therapy by arnie mendel man like that one is fascinating because like he says basically that there are channels in the sub brain and that the you know so many of these guys are really some of the best models
《身体从未忘记》，身体里的这些部位。它们也不仅仅是荣格神话式的，关于你与世界的关系，以及你如何构想自我，以及它如何与他人互动。它们是这两者共同的反映，对吧？就像球来回弹跳的方式。我内在的自我正在对这个外部世界做出反应。嗯，我身体里感觉到的东西也是一种象征。嗯，我认为其中一种比较奇怪的治疗模型——当你观察什么最受欢迎时，精华并不总是浮在上面——但去查查阿尼·门德尔的“过程疗法”，那个非常迷人，因为他基本上说大脑中存在通道，而且你知道，这些人中的许多人确实是历史上最好的治疗模型，
of therapy ever that are also the least known like voice dialogue they came out of the ex-jungian analysts they got like pissed from the 70s to the 90s and they left i mean pissed like angry not pissed like drunk maybe they did that too but i don't have any evidence of that or reason to believe it and they left the jungian institutes and they said i want a direct experience with these things i'm tired of analyzing them forever you know james hillman, I think was onto something and then, uh, became wrong about it. You know, like Hillman's always right about like the, the first thing that he believes, but archetypal psychology doesn't work because I mean, one, you're not post Jungian, you're not a Jungian anymore at all. When you throw away this concept
也是最不为人知的，比如“声音对话”，他们出自后荣格分析师，他们在70年代到90年代感到愤怒，然后离开了——我的意思是愤怒，不是喝醉了，也许他们也那样，但我没有证据或理由相信这一点——他们离开了荣格研究所，他们说：“我想要对这些东西有直接的体验，我厌倦了永远分析它们。”你知道，詹姆斯·希尔曼，我认为他发现了什么，然后，嗯，在这一点上错了。你知道，希尔曼总是对的，比如他相信的第一件事，但原型心理学行不通，因为，第一，你不再是后荣格派了，你根本不再是荣格派了。当你抛弃这个概念时，
of the self, like you need that to be a Jungian because the self is also connected to God in that model. And I'm not saying you have to believe that or use that, but if you don't do that, you're not a Jungian. Um, but you know, like the, the stone, Sidron Hellstone have this idea that there's all these sub personalities and that you, you, you analyze each of them. It's, I like the language of it more than IFS, even though they're almost the same model. Cause you don't have to have like a 30 minute explanation about like why a firefighter is a different thing than a protector and the categories of whatever like you can just be like yeah you know you don't want to feel this feeling and you have a protective part that says like hey
即“自我”，你需要它才能成为荣格派，因为在那个模型中，自我也与上帝相连。我不是说你必须相信或使用它，但如果你不这样做，你就不是荣格派。嗯，但是你知道，斯通夫妇（Sidra and Hal Stone）有这样一个想法，即存在所有这些子人格，而你分析每一个。我比IFS（内在家庭系统疗法）更喜欢它的语言，尽管它们几乎是同一个模型。因为你不需要花30分钟解释为什么“消防员”与“保护者”不同，以及各种分类什么的，你可以直接说：“是的，你知道，你不想感受到这种感觉，而你有一个保护性的部分说，嘿，
don't go there and the person's like oh the protective part is when I tap my foot and I chew my nails and I twiddle my hair and I'm like, yeah, so how old does it feel? And like, where is it in your body? And just go ahead and twiddle your hair and tap your leg. This is in voice style. You do this and, and, and really engage with it and just let it go for a minute. And then it's like, I, you know, I don't want to be here. Like the thing is like, I've got a bunch to do, and this is actually like super expensive. It's a waste of time. Like that I'm paying you is bad. And, and then they're like, Oh, I'm sorry. I shouldn't have said that. No, no, no. That's the part talking with go into that. And, and you get
别去那里。”而那个人会说：“噢，保护性的部分就是当我跺脚、咬指甲、玩弄头发的时候。”我会说：“是的，那么它感觉多大岁数了？它在你身体的什么位置？继续玩弄你的头发，跺你的腿。”这是在“声音对话”中，你这样做，并且真正地与它互动，让它持续一分钟。然后就像是，“我，你知道，我不想待在这里。就像，我还有很多事要做，这实际上超级贵。这是浪费时间。我付钱给你是很糟糕的。”然后他们会说：“噢，对不起，我不该那样说。”“不，不，不，那是那个部分在说话，深入进去。”然后你就可以
to engage with all of these different things inside of someone that disagree. I mean, it's kind of like, I see a lot of DID and therapy. And one of the things that I think is like, everybody should at least like, it teaches you a ton to work with DID because everyone thinks that way. Like not everyone has amnesia in between those parts, but there is no veil. Like you're staring directly into implicit memory. And, and when you do that, you realize like, oh, like I don't have to treat the person with DID differently than I treat any other patient because everyone has this going on in their brainstem. I'm just doing therapy in a way that, you know, honestly, they have to have a lot of insight into right away because they can't even pretend that this
与某人内心所有这些不同且相互矛盾的东西进行互动。我的意思是，这有点像，我在治疗中看到了很多DID（解离性身份障碍）。我认为有一点是，每个人至少都应该……与DID患者工作能教会你很多，因为每个人的思维方式都是那样的。并不是每个人在这些部分之间都有失忆，但没有面纱。就像你直接盯着内隐记忆看。当你这样做时，你会意识到：“噢，我不必以不同于对待其他病人的方式来对待DID患者，因为每个人的脑干里都有这种东西。”我只是以一种……老实说，他们必须立刻对这些有深刻的洞察力，因为他们甚至无法假装这个
world isn't real in the way that so many other people have the luxury of pretending, oh, no, no, no, I don't feel angry. I'm not angry with you, sir. Please stop telling me that I'm angry. You know, you're like a person with dissociative identity disorder. They, they can't, they don't have the luxury of pretending like, Oh no, I'm fine. Um, most of the time. And, um, so process therapy by Arnie Mandel, which is really interesting. It's like where he went in and said, you know, that there are these channels in the sub brain and that you could push the person into it because the body was connected to a symbol and that that symbol would show up in dreams and visually and through audio. And I think he takes it to an extreme. Um, the, the model's interesting. Um, like I see what he's doing, but, uh, well, one of the things that
世界不是真实的，就像许多其他人有奢侈去假装的那样，“噢，不，不，不，我不觉得生气。我没有对你生气，先生。请停止告诉我我在生气。”你知道，你就像一个患有解离性身份障碍的人。他们不能，他们没有奢侈去假装，“噢，不，我很好。”大多数时候。嗯，所以阿尼·门德尔的“过程疗法”，这真的很有趣。就像他进去说，你知道，大脑中存在这些通道，你可以把人推入其中，因为身体与象征相连，而那个象征会出现在梦中、视觉上和听觉上。我认为他走到了极端。嗯，这个模型很有趣。嗯，我明白他在做什么，但是，嗯，其中一件事是，
Arnie Mandel will do is, and I, I'm, I'm not saying he's lying. I'm, he probably picked his best case studies. It just, when they're all collected in a book, it's kind of funny, but like in every single one of his like case studies, he'll also like cure cancer, like be like, and then she never was afraid of her mom anymore. And the doctor told her that her incurable cancer was like, there's just too many, I don't know, like don't pick all the case studies when you're anonymizing them where somebody overcomes like a fatal illness. Maybe, maybe it does that.
阿尼·门德尔会做的是，我不是说他在撒谎，他可能挑选了他最好的案例研究。只是当它们都被收集在一本书里时，有点好笑，但在他每一个案例研究中，他也会治愈癌症，就像是，“然后她再也不怕她妈妈了。”医生告诉她，她无法治愈的癌症……就是太多了，我不知道，不要在匿名化案例研究时，挑选所有那些克服了致命疾病的案例。也许，也许它确实能做到。
I have no reason to think that it doesn't. It's just, that's one of the things that people point out. But what he would do is like, he would get the people to have, okay, well, I'm really upset about this, um, you know, thing that I'm, I'm feeling. And then find that physical reality. Like, where is that making your back tight? What are you doing? And he, you know, like Wilhelm Reich would push the place, you know, Wilhelm Reich is that psychoanalyst that gets kicks out of the institutes. He also believes in aliens and kind of goes crazy. Well, not that believing in aliens is crazy, but when you think that you can shoot aliens down with
我没有理由认为它不能。只是这是人们指出的事情之一。但他会做的是，他会让人们有，“好吧，我真的对这种……我感觉到的东西感到不安。”然后找到那种身体现实。就像，那让你的背部哪里变紧了？你在做什么？他，你知道，就像威廉·赖希会按压那个部位，你知道，威廉·赖希是那个被研究所踢出去的精神分析师。他也相信外星人，有点疯了。嗯，不是说相信外星人是疯了，但当你认为你可以用
a wet pipe in your backyard, I think, I don't think he was doing that. I think that was wrong. But Reich would push and say that there was psychic armoring, that when somebody had an emotional issue, their body became tight in a place. And he would make them get in their underwear, and he would—I think he was in his underwear, too. Am I making that up um and then he would like punch and hit and massage those places until the person like like stopped and he was a lot of it's very weird i'll do a special on reich sometime but he also like was one of the first people to connect like to the body um in a way that psychoanalysis was so obsessed with the
后院的一根湿管子把外星人打下来时，我想，我不认为他在做那个。我认为那是错的。但赖希会按压并说存在“心理盔甲”，当某人有情绪问题时，他们的身体会在某个地方变紧。他会让他们穿上内衣，他会——我想他自己也穿着内衣。我是不是编造的？嗯，然后他会像拳打脚踢和按摩那些部位，直到那个人……停止，他是一个……很多都很奇怪，我以后会做一个关于赖希的专题。但他也是第一批将身体与……联系起来的人之一，以一种精神分析如此痴迷于
unconscious but it couldn't. But Freud kept trying to make it that like, oh, my desire to want to be romantic with my mom is actually making me not be able to feel my foot. Like he kept trying to do extremely medical, you know, psychosomatic things and ignoring pretty basic ones. Like I tap my hand when I'm tired, my muscles get tight here in a way that Reich got. And so like that, when Arnie Mandel, process therapy, he hits these places and he keeps hitting them until the person gets more emotional and agitated and then relaxes and then says that, you know, that turns in all of a sudden to a symbol. He's like, what do you see?
潜意识但却做不到的方式。但弗洛伊德一直试图让它变成，“噢，我想和妈妈浪漫的欲望实际上让我无法感觉到我的脚。”他一直试图做极其医学的、你知道，心身方面的事情，而忽略了非常基本的事情。比如我累的时候会敲手，我的肌肉在这里变紧，赖希就懂这一点。所以，当阿尼·门德尔的“过程疗法”击中这些部位，他不断击打它们，直到那个人变得更加情绪化和激动，然后放松，然后说，你知道，那突然变成了一个象征。他会说：“你看到了什么？”
What do you see? What do you see? And they're like, nothing, trees. I'm remembering whatever. And that these things come up. I remember when I was running away and I was afraid and I hid in these trees after school and he's like, keep going on the visual channel. And then when the channel runs out of information, he would say, switch channels, go to the audio channel. What do you hear? What do you hear? Go back to your shoulder,
“你看到了什么？你看到了什么？”他们说：“没什么，树。我记得什么什么的。”这些东西就浮现出来了。我记得当我逃跑时，我很害怕，放学后我躲在这些树里。他说：“继续视觉通道。”然后当通道信息用尽时，他会说：“切换通道，去听觉通道。你听到了什么？你听到了什么？回到你的肩膀，”
notice your shoulder. Where's your shoulder hurting? What do you hear? And the person would be like, Oh, I hear the bullies, you know, coming after me, whatever. And then, um, you know, Mandel would say, okay, now switch channels, you know, go back to the body. Oh, now it's in my, now it's in my foot. I just feel my whole leg just feels like it's, you know, um, heavier and hot. Okay. Tap your foot, tap your foot, move. And he's poking the muscle. And in that way, it was like, he understood that there was this connection and it wasn't like, we're going to do somatic therapy to get rid of, um, you know, Zen mindfulness to relax your back. And then we're going to go talk about these emotional issues and
“注意你的肩膀。你的肩膀哪里疼？你听到了什么？”那个人会说：“噢，我听到恶霸，你知道，来找我了，什么的。”然后，嗯，你知道，门德尔会说：“好吧，现在切换通道，回到身体。”“噢，现在它在我的……现在它在我的脚里。我只是觉得我的整条腿感觉就像，你知道，更重且发热。”“好吧，跺你的脚，跺你的脚，动起来。”他在戳肌肉。通过这种方式，他明白存在这种联系，而不是说：“我们要进行躯体治疗来摆脱，嗯，你知道，禅宗正念来放松你的背部。然后我们要去谈论这些情绪问题和
how you project them on other people that my back was tight because I was trying to pretend that other people were in competition with me and my body was trying to respond to like early implicit memory formations of wanting to protect myself by raising my shoulders and looking bigger, whatever you're doing. You know, there's a connection between this that I think some models are better at the somatic part. Some are better at the kind of symbolic and relational part, but you can't do it quickly or well with only one. Like you have to understand that these things are interrelated in a way that I think it's hard for clinicians to do that. It's hard to explain it to patients. It's hard to find a model that encompasses all these things, which
你如何将它们投射到别人身上，我的背部变紧是因为我试图假装别人在和我竞争，而我的身体试图回应早期内隐记忆的形成，通过耸肩和看起来更大来保护自己，无论你在做什么。”你知道，这之间有一种联系，我认为有些模型在躯体部分做得更好。有些在象征和关系部分做得更好。但你不能只用一种就快速或出色地完成它。你必须明白这些东西是相互关联的，我认为临床医生很难做到这一点。很难向病人解释。很难找到一个涵盖所有这些东西的模型，这
is kind of why I'm talking about that. I mean, the reason I do eight models of therapy, you know, largely is because I don't think that any of them are perfect for every personality type. Like, I don't think any of them are perfect for every symptom. I don't think any of them are perfect for like every issue. Like I acquired them as I hit a block and was like, I've got to help this guy. Like, I don't know enough. And then went on a manic, you know, reading thing and learned a new model and saw it work. I learned a lot of ones that didn't work. I don't talk about them or, or I make fun of them because I tried, I tried them as a patient and as a provider and they didn't, they didn't do anything. So, um, I mean, that's why
就是我为什么谈论这个的原因。我的意思是，我做八种治疗模型，你知道，很大程度上是因为我不认为其中任何一种对每种人格类型都是完美的。我不认为它们对每种症状都是完美的。我不认为它们对每个问题都是完美的。我是在遇到瓶颈时获得它们的，当时我想：“我必须帮助这个人。我了解得不够。”然后进行了一场狂热的阅读，学习了一个新模型并看到它起作用。我学了很多不起作用的。我不谈论它们，或者我嘲笑它们，因为我作为病人和提供者尝试过它们，它们什么也没做。所以，我的意思是，这就是为什么
I've found the amount of stuff that I found. So that implicit memory, that relationship, that's such an important piece, this conception of self, right? Uh, also this idea of implicit memory and that it is partly in our body. It is partly in these implicit assumptions that we're making about the world around us all the time. You know, the way that that comes out in relationships. Or you can call it an unconscious. I don't really care what you call it, but you have to know that the person is more than they're telling you
我找到了我所发现的这些东西。所以那种内隐记忆，那种关系，那是如此重要的一部分，这种自我概念，对吧？还有这种内隐记忆的想法，它部分存在于我们的身体中。它部分存在于我们一直对周围世界做出的这些内隐假设中。你知道，它在关系中表现出来的方式。或者你可以称之为潜意识。我不在乎你叫它什么，但你必须知道，这个人比他们告诉你的要多，
because they're more than they know right now. I'm not saying that you need to be not patient-centered and you need to be Freud and tell them that, well, you know, really you would just be able to feel your foot if you would admit that you are, Freud had some, he would say that people were, it doesn't matter. Like you don't need to go into psychoanalysis. You need to be able to say, Hey, like, um, this person that I'm talking to is feeling more than they're aware of. And I'm allowed as a therapist to see how this is affecting their body, see how this is affecting their relationships, their relationship with me, you know, psychodynamic therapy. And bring that in.
因为他们比他们现在所知道的要多。我不是说你需要不以病人为中心，你需要成为弗洛伊德，告诉他们：“嗯，你知道，如果你承认你是……弗洛伊德有一些，他会说人们是……这不重要。”你不需要进行精神分析。你需要能够说：“嘿，我正在交谈的这个人感受到的比他们意识到的要多。”作为治疗师，我有权观察这如何影响他们的身体，观察这如何影响他们的关系，他们与我的关系，你知道，动力学治疗。并将其带入。
And that's something that I see people losing or they want to partial it off into the small specialization and say, I'm just going to make them experience their body and go into that energy and really experience that. And you need, yeah, that's there. But also that's affecting these other things like in my dreams, in my art, in the kind of culture that I like. You know, ask your patients the kind of music they listen to, what lyrics speak to them, you know, have conversations about what they do when they get off work, not just the thing that's stopping them from making the most money at work or whatever, because those are, you know, our culture is essentially like our psychology telling on itself, you know? Um, and I think like in the, one of the ways that you see this a ton is like, people act like, well, cause I'm not hurting somebody. Um, like the, you know, the ab you see this a ton is like people act like, well, cause I'm not
这是我看到人们正在失去的东西，或者他们想把它拆分成小的专业领域，说：“我只是要让他们体验他们的身体，进入那种能量并真正体验它。”你需要，是的，那在那里。但那也影响了其他事情，比如在我的梦里，在我的艺术里，在我喜欢的文化里。你知道，问问你的病人他们听什么音乐，什么歌词触动他们，你知道，谈谈他们下班后做什么，不仅仅是那些阻止他们在工作中赚最多钱的事情，因为那些是……我们的文化本质上就像我们的心理在自我揭露，你知道？嗯，我认为在……你看到这一点很多的一种方式是，人们表现得好像，“嗯，因为我没有伤害某人，”
hurting somebody. Um, like the, you know, the abuser did or the other people in my family did, then I'm not affected by trauma. Um, but in the eighties, like this is a huge oversimplification, but they would say like every child abuser either becomes a protector or they become a reoffender. They become a abuser. And what they're onto there, that's not true, but like what they're onto there is that when you are a victim of abuse or neglect, you know, from someone knowingly or unknowingly that they're hurting you as a kid, what happens is later you either say like, I'm never going to have that happen to me or anyone that I care about again. And you become like hyper vigilantly kind of protecting.
“就像，你知道，施虐者或其他家庭成员所做的那样，那么我就没有受到创伤。”但在八十年代，这是一个巨大的过度简化，但他们会说每个虐待儿童的人要么成为保护者，要么成为再犯者。他们成为施虐者。他们所发现的，那不是真的，但他们所发现的是，当你成为虐待或忽视的受害者时，你知道，来自某人，无论是有意还是无意，他们在小时候伤害了你，发生的事情是后来你要么说：“我永远不会让这种事发生在我或我在乎的任何人身上。”然后你变得像过度警惕地保护。
Or you just say, actually, that was a good thing. Consciously or unconsciously. That's my right. I get to do that. You know, he beat the hell out of me. I'm going to beat the hell out of my kids too. It made me a man. It taught me a lesson.
或者你只是说：“实际上，那是一件好事。”有意识或无意识地。那是我的权利。我有权那样做。你知道，他把我打得半死。我也要狠狠地打我的孩子。这让我成为了一个男人。它给我上了一课。
There is no trauma. So one of those is putting the abuse outward, just repeating it. And the other one is taking it inward and saying I'm going to be aware of pain. I'm never going to not see. I'm never going to be the one who doesn't say this is what's going on.
没有创伤。所以其中一个是把虐待向外投射，只是重复它。另一个是把它向内吸收，说：“我要意识到痛苦。我永远不会不去看。我永远不会成为那个不说‘这就是正在发生的事情’的人。”
I'll never do that. And when you do that, you become a therapist a lot of the time, but you're still traumatized. I mean, taking too much responsibility is more, is just as bad as taking none, you know, and the abuser didn't take any because when you're going inward, I mean, so just in the same way that the person who is like reoffending, abusing their child or something is afraid of being a victim. They're afraid of being weak. They're afraid of being hurt back then.
“我永远不会那样做。”当你这样做时，你很多时候会成为一名治疗师，但你仍然受到创伤。我的意思是，承担太多责任和承担一点责任一样糟糕，你知道，而施虐者没有承担任何责任，因为当你向内看时，我的意思是，就像那个再犯、虐待孩子的人害怕成为受害者一样。他们害怕变得软弱。他们害怕当时被伤害。
So I'm going to say I didn't, it didn't hurt me and I'm fine. And I'm going to keep doing it because to prove that I wasn't hurt at all. Right. They're afraid of being the inward person. They're afraid of being the victim. Well, the therapist, the intuitive person who's taking that trauma and putting it inward, they're afraid of being the victim. Well, the therapist, the intuitive person who's taking that trauma and putting it inward, they're afraid of being the abuser. And so they're saying, hey, like, I don't want to be the abuser. And so every time there's anybody who is, you know, who could maybe be hurt
所以我打算说：“它没有伤害我，我很好。”并且我会继续这样做，以证明我根本没有受到伤害。对吧？他们害怕成为向内看的人。他们害怕成为受害者。嗯，治疗师，那个吸收创伤并将其向内的直觉型的人，他们害怕成为施虐者。所以他们说：“嘿，我不想成为施虐者。”所以每当有任何人，你知道，谁可能被我伤害时，
by me, I'll just go ahead and make sure that like, I just am the bigger person and I deal with it and I never hurt them. So sometimes you're enabling them. And other times you're in a relationship you don't want to be in. Or somebody just has your number because they can say like, oh, my boundaries are that you have to make me a ham sandwich. If you don't make me a ham sandwich, I don't feel safe. You know, and now I'm getting manipulated and feeling like, well, I'm strong enough to do this or whatever. But there is a lot of that there. I mean, the point is not to do either.
我会继续确保，就像，我只是做一个更大度的人，我处理它，我从不伤害他们。所以有时你在纵容他们。而其他时候，你处于一段你不想处于的关系中。或者某人只是拿捏住了你，因为他们可以说：“噢，我的界限是你必须给我做一个火腿三明治。如果你不给我做火腿三明治，我就觉得不安全。”你知道，现在我被操纵了，感觉像，“嗯，我有足够的能力做这个，”什么的。但那里有很多那种东西。我的意思是，重点是不要做任何一种。
And we always feel good because we're not being the other one. So we don't have the problem. Until you get something like the ping pong ball of implicit memory, and I'm moving into my third point here, the last one, the externalized world and our sense of agency, right? Because I think a ton of times therapy is talking about things, but not really knowing like what it wants us to do or how to think about what the point of itself is, which is a big conversation. And so I would say it's not to go inward or outward with trauma and blame to be a victim. It's not to be an abuser. It's to deal with that implicit memory
我们总是感觉良好，因为我们没有成为另一种人。所以我们没有问题。直到你得到像内隐记忆的乒乓球那样的东西，我正在进入我的第三点，最后一点，外在化的世界和我们的代理感，对吧？因为我认为很多时候治疗是在谈论事情，但并不真正知道它想要我们做什么，或者如何思考它的意义是什么，这是一个很大的对话。所以我认为不是带着创伤和责备向内或向外去成为受害者。不是成为施虐者。而是处理那种内隐记忆，
response that makes that unconscious to where I would enable somebody, or I would continue to do the abuse. It's to go inward and see that that implicit memory is like, I'm afraid of being that either in the future, the abuser in the future, or I'm afraid of being the victim back then. I can't even deal with how weak I felt. So I'm going to say that it was good and it made me strong and it wasn't actually weak. And I never have to deal with how I felt. Like people don't say these things in that way, but therapy models that are good have to conceptualize this stuff in a way that lets us see it. And we're never going to get the metaphor perfect because we're in a part of the brain that doesn't speak English. And to a certain extent, it doesn't understand time. Like it thinks that we are the same age that we were when we were abused,
那种让潜意识变得如此的反应，以至于我会纵容某人，或者我会继续进行虐待。它是向内看，看到那种内隐记忆就像是，“我害怕在未来成为那个施虐者，或者我害怕成为当时的受害者。”我甚至无法处理我当时感觉有多软弱。所以我打算说它是好的，它让我变得强大，它实际上并不软弱。我永远不必处理我的感受。人们不会那样说这些话，但好的治疗模型必须以一种让我们看到它的方式来概念化这些东西。我们永远不会把隐喻弄得完美，因为我们处于大脑中一个不说英语的部分。在某种程度上，它不理解时间。就像它认为我们和被虐待时是同一个年龄，
which is why it's doing this thing to our body is because it doesn't know time. There's a, I'll take a break and read a, read a Robert Penn Warren poem called The Riddle in the Garden, right? My mind is intact, but the shapes of the world change, And the peach has released the bough And at last it makes full confession Its pure dour has departed like peach fuzz Wiped off and we know now How the hot sweetness of the flesh And the juice dark hug
这就是为什么它对我们的身体做这件事，因为它不知道时间。有一个……我会休息一下，读一首罗伯特·潘·沃伦的诗，叫《花园里的谜题》，对吧？我的思想完好无损，但世界的形状变了，桃子已经离开了树枝，最终它做出了充分的忏悔，它纯粹的严厉已经像桃毛一样消失了，擦掉了，我们现在知道，果肉的热甜味和深色的汁液拥抱，
The rough peach pit we know its most suicidal yearnings It wants to suffer extremely and the juice dark hug, the rough peach pit, we know its most suicidal yearnings. It wants to suffer extremely. It loves God, and I warn you, do not touch that plum. It will burn you. A blister will be on your finger, and you will put the finger to your lips for relief. Oh, do be careful not to break that soft gray bulge of the brute skin, for exposing that inwardness will increase your pain for you are part of this world and you think that i speak in riddles but i am not
粗糙的桃核，我们知道它最自杀的渴望。它想要极度受苦，深色的汁液拥抱，粗糙的桃核，我们知道它最自杀的渴望。它想要极度受苦。它爱上帝，我警告你，不要碰那个李子。它会灼伤你。你的手指上会起水泡，你会把手指放在嘴唇上寻求缓解。噢，一定要小心不要弄破那块粗糙皮肤的柔软灰色隆起，因为暴露那种内在性会增加你的痛苦，因为你是这个世界的一部分，你认为我说话像谜语，但我不是。
the world means only itself so a lot going on here like why i picked this one i read this at a yun gang conference and um didn't go over well well i think that's some unbaked wood is what really threw them but you've got some garden of eden stuff like you if you reach for the fruit which why does the fruit want to be eaten right it has a seed in it and we wouldn't pick it up and eat it and go drop the seed somewhere. So there could be a new tree if it didn't taste good. So the peach is suicidal. Like it wants to die in order for itself to live.
世界只意味着它自己。所以这里发生了很多事，为什么我选这一首，我在一个荣格会议上读过这个，嗯，效果不好。嗯，我想是一些未烤熟的木头真正困扰了他们，但你有一些伊甸园的东西，就像如果你伸手去拿水果，为什么水果想被吃掉，对吧？它里面有一颗种子，如果我们不把它捡起来吃掉，去把种子掉在某个地方。如果它不好吃，就不会有新树。所以桃子是自杀的。就像它想死，为了它自己能活。
But then also if you touch it, your finger will blister and you will put that finger to your lips for relief. So don't break the gray bulge of the blister like fruit skin. So the fruit itself is the blister. Like you, the, the, the fruit is a blister that is hurting and pain and suicidal. Um, that when we eat drops a seed by exposing this inwardness, we increase your pain for you are part of this world. You think that I speak in riddles, but I'm not for the world means only itself. To take that peach, that first like fruit and leave Eden separated us from God. Um, but it also taught us what God was in a way that we didn't know before. Um, I think Edward Edinger would have loved this point. The world itself
但如果触碰它，你的手指会起水泡，你会把那个手指放在嘴唇上寻求缓解。所以不要弄破像水果皮一样的灰色水泡隆起。所以水果本身就是水泡。就像你，水果是一个正在受伤、痛苦和自杀的水泡。嗯，当我们吃掉它时，掉下一颗种子，通过暴露这种内在性，我们增加了你的痛苦，因为你是这个世界的一部分。你认为我说话像谜语，但我不是，因为世界只意味着它自己。拿走那个桃子，那个最初的水果，离开伊甸园使我们与上帝分离。嗯，但它也以一种我们以前不知道的方式教会了我们上帝是什么。嗯，我想爱德华·埃丁格会喜欢这个观点。世界本身
is the garden here is the blister and it is the fruit. It life is a swelling and you can't have one part of that process without accepting all of it. And so that swelling and the growth of the fruit is also the swelling in the growth of a blister of pain. And the peach only exists to be eaten, to die, and we eat the peach to grow the next one. So not to touch the suicidal peach is to not touch life itself. For to live is to be hurt and to grow. And this process has only the meaning that we allow ourselves to give it. So to touch the peach is to become part of the world, like Adam and Eve found out. You know, it hurts and it blisters and we put our finger to our lips after touching the fruit. But we also know that we are ourself. Uh, and we also know God, like we,
就是花园，这里是水泡，它是水果。生命是一种膨胀，你不能在不接受整个过程的情况下拥有那个过程的一部分。所以那种膨胀和水果的生长也是痛苦水泡的膨胀和生长。桃子存在的目的就是被吃掉，去死，我们吃桃子来生长下一个。所以不触碰自杀的桃子就是不触碰生命本身。因为活着就是受伤和成长。这个过程只有我们允许自己赋予它的意义。所以触碰桃子就是成为世界的一部分，就像亚当和夏娃发现的那样。你知道，它很痛，会起水泡，我们在触碰水果后把手指放在嘴唇上。但我们也知道我们是自己。嗯，我们也知道上帝，就像我们，
we know we become separate from the system enough to see it. And now that we've seen it, what do we do with it? And, and that question of like, what do we do with it? That is one of the most important questions in therapy. It's one that I can't answer for you and you can't answer for your patients. And you really can't quite answer all the way for yourself. Not in the ego, not in the intellect. Because where you answer that question is going to be an implicit memory. It's going to be in this place where you go in and you see the world in a way that is okay, where you are okay and you are safe and you are loved
我们知道我们变得足够脱离系统来看到它。现在我们看到了它，我们用它做什么？那个“我们用它做什么”的问题，那是治疗中最重要的问题之一。这是我无法为你回答的，你也无法为你的病人回答。你真的不能完全为你自己回答。不是在自我中，不是在智力中。因为你回答那个问题的地方将是内隐记忆。它将是在这个地方，你进去，以一种还可以的方式看待世界，在那里你是好的，你是安全的，你是被爱的，
and you can love others and you can love yourself. And then you don't get to stay there. Then you have to fall again and you have to go back and you have to kind of forget that stuff. And then you have to remember that you can feel this way and that this can be real. And hitting that moving target of self, and you know, my language here is going to lean pretty Jungian because I lean pretty Jungian, but that doesn't mean that you have to. I'm telling you my metaphors so that you can make your own. You know, David Tacey said, I think this is Melbourne Jung Society had this on their website, but we, from a talk he gave there in Melbourne, but we move forward by paradoxically going back, remembering the lost wisdom and the
你可以爱别人，你可以爱自己。然后你不能待在那里。然后你必须再次坠落，你必须回去，你必须有点忘记那些东西。然后你必须记住你可以有这种感觉，这可以是真实的。击中那个移动的自我目标，你知道，我这里的语言会倾向于荣格派，因为我倾向于荣格派，但这并不意味着你必须这样做。我告诉你我的隐喻，这样你就可以创造你自己的。你知道，大卫·塔西说，我想这是墨尔本荣格协会在他们的网站上有这个，但我们，来自他在墨尔本的一次演讲，但我们通过矛盾地回到过去来前进，记住失去的智慧和
legacy of the human soul. Our longing is fulfilled when we recover our central belongingness to the mystery of the universe. And this is the meaning of individuation to realize our place in the greater whole and to live in service of that all encompassing reality. Like this is a post secular sacred idea. Um, you know, Tacey's big on post-secular sacred, that you can go into this phase of life where we're primitive and we believe in mythology. And then we have a new era where religion becomes kind of largely cultural or unconscious, where spirituality is active and we believe in empiricism. And then that fails us. And that third phase, which I think we're moving into now, it's being like science is real, literalized mythology is not good, but also science is going to fail. You know, what is it
人类灵魂的遗产。当我们恢复我们对宇宙奥秘的中心归属感时，我们的渴望就得到了满足。这就是个体化的意义，意识到我们在更大的整体中的位置，并为那个包罗万象的现实服务。就像这是一个后世俗的神圣理念。嗯，你知道，塔西非常推崇后世俗神圣，你可以进入生命的这个阶段，我们是原始的，我们相信神话。然后我们有一个新时代，宗教变得在很大程度上是文化性的或无意识的，灵性是活跃的，我们相信经验主义。然后那失败了。而第三阶段，我认为我们现在正在进入，就像科学是真实的，字面化的神话是不好的，但科学也会失败。你知道，它是什么
that like Socrates said about like the hyperbole of reason becoming a dangerous or something, you know, he's saying that like when reason becomes this end to itself, like those large language model, you know, Silicon Valley people that think we can turn a robot into a person because they think that people are robots, um, believe. And we have to find a way to reconnect with what this world means in therapy. But at the same time, you can't just tell your patient, yeah, convert to Christianity, live for Christ, walk in his ways, and that gets you to the divine. Maybe that worked for you. Maybe that works for the patient.
苏格拉底说的关于理性的夸张变得危险什么的，你知道，他在说当理性成为它自己的终点时，就像那些大型语言模型，你知道，硅谷那些认为我们可以把机器人变成人的人，因为他们认为人是机器人，相信。我们必须在治疗中找到一种方法来重新连接这个世界意味着什么。但同时，你不能只告诉你的病人：“是的，皈依基督教，为基督而活，走他的路，那会带你走向神圣。”也许这对你有效。也许这对病人有效。
But you can't tell them to do that. You have to help them feel these tensions. And in feeling those tensions, they will start to recoil and be afraid. And then slowly when you've done it and you're brave and you go in there, then the patient starts to feel excited. The fear is transmuted into excitement because it's the same energy. And they start to hold kind of maybe a terrible awe, but an awe for the beauty of this thing and the absurdity of it and the paradoxes of it and the finality of it, but also the impermanence, and maybe the inevitability, and the mystical connection to all of the things that make us human that a robot cannot feel. And then in those, they see stories, they see ways of being. They see themselves.
但你不能告诉他们那样做。你必须帮助他们感受这些张力。在感受这些张力时，他们会开始退缩和害怕。然后慢慢地，当你做到了，你很勇敢，你进入那里，然后病人开始感到兴奋。恐惧被转化为兴奋，因为那是同样的能量。他们开始持有某种也许是可怕的敬畏，但对这个东西的美、荒谬、悖论和终极性，但也包括无常，也许是必然性，以及所有使我们成为人类的神秘联系，这是机器人无法感受到的。然后在那里面，他们看到了故事，他们看到了存在的方式。他们看到了他们自己。
But it isn't an intellectual journey. It's going through that implicit memory response that I'm talking about. The best models of therapy do. I didn't make any of this up. Like, I'm not telling you how I do therapy. I mean, I am, but I'm not telling you that because I think this is the best way. And I wrote all this down. Like what I did is read the history of the profession.
但这并不是一段智力之旅。它是经历我所说的内隐记忆反应。最好的治疗模型会这样做。我没有编造任何这些。就像，我不是在告诉你我如何做治疗。我的意思是，我是，但我不是在告诉你那个，因为我认为这是最好的方式。我写下了所有这些。就像我所做的是阅读这个行业的历史。
And this is something that is human. It's not, this is something that is in every model of therapy that is good. And something that is in most religions that did not become cults, things that became parts of culture because they were human and beneficial. I mean, if you go back to ancient Greece, the pre-Socratic philosophers, like they're going to tell you that the origin of the soul, you know, is like air or something that's invisible. You know, there's this idea in Greece where language hasn't made
这是人类的东西。它不是……这是每个好的治疗模型中都有的东西。也是大多数没有变成邪教的宗教中都有的东西，那些成为文化一部分的东西，因为它们是人类的且有益的。我的意思是，如果你回到古希腊，前苏格拉底哲学家，他们会告诉你灵魂的起源，你知道，是空气或某种看不见的东西。你知道，在希腊有一种想法，语言还没有做出
the, we haven't made like the semantic and linguistic distinctions enough to separate the idea of like life from the idea of logic and thinking, um, from the idea from also the ability to move and have agency, you know, like Aristotle says, there's like a vegetative soul that is like a vegetable that just means the things alive, like a mushroom. And then there's like a vegetative soul that is like a vegetable that just means the thing's alive, like a mushroom. And then there's, you know, the sensate soul that is, um, able to like go and move and do something that an animal has that a mushroom doesn't, but that, um, there's the rational soul. Um, I'm not going to try and pronounce Greek here, guys sorry um and that rational soul is um something that gives mankind the ability to reason and understand death in a way that an animal or a mushroom can't
我们还没有做出足够的语义和语言区分来将“生命”的概念与“逻辑”和“思考”的概念分开，嗯，从……也从移动和拥有代理权的能力分开，你知道，就像亚里斯多德说的，有一种“植物灵魂”，就像蔬菜，只是意味着东西是活的，像蘑菇。然后有……有一种“植物灵魂”，就像蔬菜，只是意味着东西是活的，像蘑菇。然后有，你知道，“感官灵魂”，它是，嗯，能够去移动和做一些动物有而蘑菇没有的事情，但那……有“理性灵魂”。嗯，我不会在这里尝试发音希腊语，伙计们，抱歉，嗯，那个理性灵魂是……某种赋予人类推理和理解死亡能力的东西，这是动物或蘑菇做不到的
um you know like these are attempts to separate the phenomenology this experience of being human into these things that let us make sense of it, that let us see the world and see ourself. Because like the reason that, and that's why this was kind of a hard thing to structure, is that I needed to talk about three concepts, but all these concepts definition are reflexive to each other. They're like tarot cards. You can't like discard one of them and get rid of it. And because you can't discard one of them and get rid of it, that means that you have to talk about all three of them to talk about any of them. The self is always in communication with the world. That idea of who we are is always being colored and overcorrected by implicit memory and trauma in that area.
嗯，你知道，这些是试图将现象学，这种作为人类的体验，分解成这些让我们理解它的东西，让我们看到世界和看到我们自己。因为就像原因，这就是为什么这是一种很难构建的东西，因为我需要谈论三个概念，但所有这些概念的定义都是相互反射的。它们就像塔罗牌。你不能丢弃其中一张并摆脱它。因为你不能丢弃其中一张并摆脱它，这意味着你必须谈论所有三张才能谈论其中任何一张。自我总是与世界交流。那种关于我们是谁的想法总是被内隐记忆和该区域的创伤所着色和过度修正。
And then our relationship to the self and our sense of agency and what we're supposed to do in therapy, that's always going to be a relationship. And so when you, when you get into the people who sort of hide avoidantly, like in one part of life, like they're saying, okay, well like spiritual bypassing in a mystical community or the of life. Like they're saying, okay, well like spiritual bypassing in a mystical community or the new age movement, they're like, oh, well I don't have to go out and like vote or do civil rights or anything. I just have to manifest and my energy will go out across the ley lines through my amethyst and that will change. And they're like, well, this person's hungry and they're right here. Could you help out? No, no, no, I'm above the material.
然后我们与自我的关系，我们的代理感，以及我们在治疗中应该做什么，那总是会是一种关系。所以当你，当你进入那些在生活的一部分中以回避方式隐藏的人时，就像他们说，“好吧，嗯，就像神秘社区或新时代运动中的精神绕道，他们说，‘噢，好吧，我不必出去投票或做民权什么的。我只需要显化，我的能量就会通过我的紫水晶穿过地脉，那就会改变。’”他们说，“好吧，这个人饿了，他们就在这里。你能帮帮忙吗？”“不，不，不，我高于物质。”
That isn't a helpful relationship. You have this kind of sense of agency that isn't really being actualized to help you be effective there. It also isn't great to just pour everything externally and go out and not know who you are because there's so much pain in the world. A lot of mystics and intuitive feelers fall prey to this. I mean, I think this is why Simone Weil, you know, one of the mystics that I like died of an eating disorder saying, you know, I'm not going to eat until everyone in the world is fed, is that they want to live kind of for the pain in the world because they mistake their own pain for this pain in the world. And that, you know, Gandhi idea of be the change you want to see when
那不是一种有益的关系。你有一种并没有真正被实现来帮助你在那里有效的代理感。把一切都倾注到外部，走出去却不知道自己是谁，也不是很好，因为世界上有太多的痛苦。许多神秘主义者和直觉型的人沦为牺牲品。我的意思是，我认为这就是为什么西蒙娜·薇依，你知道，我喜欢的神秘主义者之一，死于饮食失调，说：“你知道，在世界上每个人都吃饱之前，我是不会吃的。”是因为他们想为世界上的痛苦而活，因为他们把自己的痛苦误认为是世界上的痛苦。而那，你知道，甘地“成为你想看到的改变”的想法，当
you don't have something in your heart, when you don't have something, when you have a pain, go out and help somebody that has that same pain. And that's how you heal. That's, that's good, but you also can't heal yourself only by healing other people. You have to be aware that you're doing that because you're hurting in order to change. So I guess, you know, kind of just start to wrap up this idea of what do you do with the idea of the implicit memory being underneath the ego or, you know, the aware self. And then this conception of self being these dynamic forces that we have to kind of learn to balance, but not ever really like fix, um, or make static in the way that I think the worst models of therapy, try and make them static. We're going to go from an eight to a 10. Now you're better.
当你内心空虚，当你感到痛苦时，去帮助那些同样承受这种痛苦的人。这就是治愈之道。这很好，但你不能仅仅通过治愈他人来治愈自己。你必须意识到，你这样做是因为你内心也在受伤，为了改变而采取行动。所以我想，我们开始总结一下这个观点：当隐性记忆处于自我或意识自我之下时，你该如何处理？以及这种将自我视为动态力量的观念，我们必须学会平衡，而不是试图去“修复”它，或者像某些糟糕的心理治疗模式那样，试图将其固定化。我们不能说从8分提升到10分，你就变好了。
Um, yeah, but what are you going from an eight to a 10 do over here? You know, we are an ecosystem. And to go in and say, we're going to introduce kudzu into Alabama because we want to get rid of erosion, and we found this fast growing vine in Japan, does something else. You know, maybe that takes anxiety away. And now this addiction is eating your highways. Like, we have to think of psychology in that way and things that are highly empirical and things that are driven by a lot of categorization and a lot of specialization, um, you know, in health delivery, you know, the, well, you can't talk about the body and the mind. I write the pills.
嗯，是的，但从8分提升到10分，你在这里到底做了什么？我们是一个生态系统。如果有人说，我们要把葛藤引入阿拉巴马州来防止水土流失，因为我们在日本发现这种藤蔓生长迅速，结果却引发了其他问题。也许这能缓解焦虑，但现在这种“成瘾”却在吞噬你的生活。我们必须以这种方式思考心理学。那些高度经验主义、过度分类和过度专业化的东西，在医疗服务中，你不能把身体和心灵割裂开来。我只负责开药。
She rubs the leg when it gets hurt at tennis. He does the three therapy interventions for cognitive behavioral therapy. These don't really need to be separate jobs. I'm not saying they need to be the same. But making them so specialized and individual is this byproduct of this highly objective empirical system. And it's like needs for profit motive and healthcare. Um, and it's needs to create credentialism, um, to create hierarchies and bureaucracies that I would argue don't need to be there, which is why I start with that academic intro, um, and don't make anyone better. Um, and the people who they make financially
她打网球受伤时会揉揉腿，他会进行认知行为疗法的三个干预步骤。这些工作其实没必要完全分开。我不是说它们必须完全一样，但将它们过度专业化和个体化，是这种高度客观的经验主义系统的副产品。这是医疗保健中利润动机的需求，是创造证书制度的需求，是为了建立那些我认为根本没必要的等级制度和官僚机构。这就是为什么我从学术介绍开始，因为它们并没有让任何人变得更好。而且那些在经济上获益的人，
better off probably don't deserve to be financially better off. You know, but all of those things, what they're doing is taking you away from this idea of the self being an ecosystem of dynamic parts. You know, it's not ADHD. It's anxiety that is happening when you don't have something that you need as a kid. And so you're becoming hypervigilant because you're trying to pay attention to everything at once with all of your attention, which isn't possible. So none of your attention is going anywhere, right? Like that's a more helpful way to think about it than a DSM code. And then a list of interventions that have been proven to work for that, except the way that we proved that they worked for it wasn't really even that scientific, even though it fell within the realms of objective science. Um, and, and so I, I don't know, coming
可能并不值得获得这些经济利益。但所有这些做法，都在让你偏离“自我是一个动态部分的生态系统”这一理念。你知道，那不是多动症（ADHD）。那是当你童年缺乏某种需求时产生的焦虑。你变得过度警觉，因为你试图用所有的注意力同时关注每一件事，而这根本不可能。所以你的注意力实际上哪里都没去，对吧？这比DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）代码以及一堆所谓的“已被证明有效”的干预措施更有参考价值，尽管我们证明它们有效的方式甚至算不上真正的科学，即便它们属于客观科学的范畴。所以，我不知道，回到
back to how do we decide what we're supposed to do? You know, when people talk about spiritual bypass, when they think like Jung and meditation and this stuff is BS, it's not because it isn't, um, plenty of people have said, I'm going to use my chakra to manifest change and then continued to go out and been a terror in all of their relationships and not learned anything in therapy. And that's what the new age people would call spiritual bypass. Mindfulness in a vacuum, I don't know if that is going to make you grow up. Just in the same way that one person may take psychedelics and have this incredible intentional experience,
我们该如何决定自己应该做什么？当人们谈论“灵性逃避”时，当他们认为荣格、冥想这些东西是胡扯时，并不是因为它们真的没用。很多人说“我要用脉轮来显化改变”，结果在所有的人际关系中依然是个灾难，在治疗中什么也没学到。这就是新时代人士所说的“灵性逃避”。在真空中谈论正念，我不知道这是否能让你真正成熟。就像一个人服用迷幻药可能会获得不可思议的意向性体验，
somebody else may just watch the band on stage be kind of trippy looking. You turning off your ego doesn't have to teach you something. And so saying that the point of therapy is just to dwell in implicit memory forever, I don't think that's true. It's to have a relationship between these internal things that we have in our concept of self and understand how our implicit memory is making us interact with those things in an external world that is real. Your subjective and objective worlds are real. And when I'm saying that we have to bring both into conscious awareness and make both of them a part of therapy, I don't mean we have to balance like, oh, there's objective life where I do work and subjective life where I do yoga and art,
而另一些人可能只是看着舞台上的乐队觉得很酷炫。关闭你的自我并不一定能教给你什么。所以，认为心理治疗的意义仅仅是永远沉浸在隐性记忆中，我不认为这是对的。治疗的意义在于，在我们拥有的这些内在事物与自我概念之间建立一种关系，并理解我们的隐性记忆是如何让我们在真实的外部世界中与这些事物互动的。你的主观世界和客观世界都是真实的。当我提到我们必须将两者都带入意识层面并使它们成为治疗的一部分时，我并不是说我们要像平衡工作与生活那样去平衡——哦，客观生活是我工作，主观生活是我做瑜伽和艺术，
and I need to have both work-life balance. Like, no, what I mean is that they have to be reflective of one another, that they have to have a symmetry. And that if we're not making a kind of therapy that is bringing those things into awareness as being connected through this relationship to the internal external world. Oh no, it doesn't matter. I just dealt with it with my, you know, uh, amethyst energy. Like maybe you just don't want to deal with it. And so you're pretending that a rock is magic. And I'm not saying that rocks aren't magic or that you can't have, you know, crystals and things that mean something to you. It's that, is the thing that you're trying to do actually solving the problem you're
我需要两者平衡。不，我的意思是它们必须相互映射，必须具有对称性。如果我们创造的治疗方式不能将这些事物作为通过这种关系连接到内外世界的纽带带入意识，那就不行。“哦，没关系，我用我的紫水晶能量处理过了。”也许你只是不想面对它，所以你假装石头有魔力。我并不是说石头没有魔力，或者你不能拥有对你有意义的水晶。问题是，你试图做的事情真的解决了你试图解决的问题吗？
trying to solve? I think the goal of therapy is to make you effective at being yourself. And we've obfuscated that by playing with the definitions of these words and sometimes trying to remove the concept entirely from therapy and it doesn't work for me when you get rid of any of them because you can imperfectly know what the self is you can imperfectly see implicit memory so yes these are going to be much muddy concepts it's a soft science but you can't lose that the point of therapy is to make somebody effective at being them once Once you start to try
我认为心理治疗的目标是让你能够有效地做你自己。我们通过玩弄这些词汇的定义，有时甚至试图将这个概念完全从治疗中剔除，从而混淆了这一点。当你抛弃任何一个概念时，对我来说这行不通，因为你只能不完美地了解自我，只能不完美地看到隐性记忆。所以，是的，这些概念会很模糊，这是一门软科学，但你不能忘记，心理治疗的意义在于让一个人能够有效地做他自己。一旦你开始尝试
and get rid of that and make it more medical than that, I think you've lost me. You know, there has to be a symmetry between these internal and external objects. Like they have to be synced and we have to realize that this is a reflection that like, yes, you know, my religion does say something about my fears. My art does say something about my ambitions. My avoidance does say something about my rage, that like these things are connected in a way that we've just kind of given up on connecting. And what happens when you don't make this jump is evil. I mean, it is evil, not like Hitler or somebody goes out and, you know, sometimes that happens. But the majority
摆脱这一点，使其变得更加医学化，我想你就失去我了。你知道，这些内在和外在对象之间必须存在对称性。它们必须同步，我们必须意识到这是一种映射。是的，我的宗教信仰确实反映了我的恐惧，我的艺术确实反映了我的抱负，我的回避确实反映了我的愤怒。这些事物以一种我们已经放弃连接的方式相互关联。而当你没有跨出这一步时，邪恶就会发生。我是说，这确实是邪恶的，不是说像希特勒那样去杀人，虽然有时也会发生。但大多数
of the reason that evil happens is that somebody says, I can't even look at this system that is so self-evidently awful and helps no one and just say it's bad. I'm not asking you to say it out loud. I'm not asking you to change it, to have a political answer, to even care about it. I'm just saying, like, when we look at this and say, this doesn't work, this is bad. If you have a reaction where you're like, oh, but you can't say that. And like, that's evil, right? Because what you're doing is cutting yourself off from you because you already know it. You're just having this because, you know, of things going on, implicit memory reaction of like, you're not allowed to know that I'm not allowed to know that we're not allowed to say that. And the, the, that is, I think not only the solution
邪恶发生的原因是，有人说：“我甚至无法直视这个显而易见糟糕且对任何人都没有帮助的系统，并说它很糟糕。”我不是要求你大声说出来，不是要求你改变它，不是要求你给出政治答案，甚至不需要你关心它。我只是说，当我们看着这一切并说“这行不通，这很糟糕”时，如果你有种反应是“哦，但你不能那样说”，那这就是邪恶，对吧？因为你正在切断与自我的联系，因为你内心深处已经知道了。你只是因为隐性记忆的反应，觉得“我不被允许知道，我不被允许说出来”。我认为，这不仅是解决
to the problems that, you know, clinical therapy is having right now, trying to find a place in the world, um, and in healthcare and in life and culture, but also the root of its problems, you know, is people not doing this, these things, doing therapy, and then making the problems worse by avoiding them. Let's stop avoiding them. There's like one of the, my favorite moments in any movie, there's a documentary called into eternity and it's about finland um trying to store nuclear waste and it's this teeny tiny country it's not like they're making the majority of nuclear waste in the world and they're like this stuff is toxic and lethal for a hundred thousand years so how do we keep it away from people for a hundred thousand years because our
临床治疗目前在世界、医疗保健、生活和文化中寻找定位所面临问题的方案，也是其问题的根源。人们不做这些事，不做真正的治疗，反而通过逃避问题使问题变得更糟。让我们停止逃避吧。我最喜欢的电影片段之一，有一部纪录片叫《永恒之中》（Into Eternity），讲的是芬兰试图储存核废料。这是一个非常小的国家，并不是说他们制造了世界上大部分的核废料，但他们意识到这些东西有毒且致命，持续时间长达十万年。所以我们该如何让人们在十万年内远离它？因为我们的
civilizations like you know a couple thousand old that we even know, like, will there even be people around? And if they are, they may not speak English. Maybe we should put scary spikes on stuff. And those scary spikes will tell people who may not even know English or have survived a, you know, a Holocaust or desert climate change, whatever they're trying to prepare for everything. They're really just so genuinely trying to solve problems that are a hundred thousand years from now in this movie which is so funny because we're in a world that can't solve a problem that's you know right in front of its face um and the scientist who's in it you know he's just talking so dry the whole time about like and it's translated so it's like just adjusting his glasses and like being like, well, the rotting girls will go down.
文明，你知道，我们所知的也就几千年历史。未来还会有人类吗？如果有人，他们可能不会说英语。也许我们应该在上面放些可怕的尖刺。那些可怕的尖刺会告诉那些可能不懂英语、或者在浩劫或气候变化中幸存下来的人。无论他们试图为一切做准备，他们真的只是在真诚地试图解决十万年后的问题。这部电影很有趣，因为我们生活在一个连眼前的问题都解决不了的世界里。片中的科学家，他一直用非常枯燥的语气谈论，而且是翻译过来的，他只是调整着眼镜说：“嗯，腐烂的女孩会下去。”
You know, the half-life is this. And so 100,000, but lethal for whatever. And they keep asking him these questions that have a poetic sensibility. And he just answers with rote science. The last shot in the movie, you know, it's a documentary, so I'm not spoiling anything. I don't know. The last shot in the movie is them looking at him. And you've watched this film where just the concept of 100,000 years has sank down on you.
你知道，半衰期是这样的。所以十万年，但致命性如何如何。他们不断问他一些带有诗意感的问题，而他只是用死记硬背的科学知识来回答。电影的最后一个镜头，你知道，这是纪录片，所以我不会剧透。我不知道。电影的最后一个镜头是他们看着他。你看了这部电影，那种十万年的概念沉重地压在你身上。
And you keep being like, yeah, a long time, long time, long time. And then they keep talking about the change in the planet and how they have to protect it. And you slowly just realize like the vastness of time over this movie in a way that's like really horrifying and then at the very end he asks the director asks the scientist a pretty technical question and he answers and then he says when you think about the future do you have hope and the first time he doesn't say anything and he just like looks to the side and his glasses kind of droop down and he sheds like a single tear. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你不断地想：“是的，很长的时间，很长的时间。”然后他们继续谈论地球的变化以及他们必须如何保护它。你慢慢意识到，这部电影中时间的广度是如此令人恐惧。在最后，导演问了科学家一个相当技术性的问题，他回答了，然后导演问：“当你想到未来时，你有希望吗？”第一次，他什么也没说，只是看向一边，眼镜滑落下来，流下了一滴眼泪。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。